Or live Neil Brennan in the middle of
tweeting.
What are you doing?
I'm using my Samsung Galaxy right now.
Says a beautiful phone.
Hi.
To me.
Your voice is so commercial.
Thanks very much.
You were on stage the other night and
the belly room and we were in the green
room.
We're like,
his voice is so commercial.
Like it sounds like that God damn car.
So I'll never be able to separate them.
Now I know I shouldn't say that
commercial.
Just say that series of commercials.
How many of those fucking things you'd
done?
I,
you know what?
I don't know.
Probably 30.
I just do sessions and then they do
whatever they want.
We should do other shit man.
If you were just doing that and then you
became the verizon guy,
you know.
Can you hear me now?
Like that guy.
That guy's fucked.
Fuck fucked.
You're getting a dell.
Oh that guy's fucked.
How about the girl?
The insurance girl.
It's always know.
Is that a name?
Yeah,
but they.
At least they keep making those.
She is fucked once she's done though,
but she's probably made a killing by
this point.
Hopefully,
but is it worth it?
The first one,
but that guy from that fucking
commercial that always gets in the
accidents and falls down and gets hurt,
you know that a handsome gentleman,
he,
they cast him in a lot of shit.
He's in movies too.
He's always in movies.
He was in John Wick.
He's been.
John Wick was good,
right?
Fuck yeah.
What I've heard,
it's good.
I just haven't watched it.
I mean it's no like brilliant,
like super creative,
undeniable work of art.
But it's funny shit as far as like a
really wild,
crazy entertainment.
It's just,
it's like crazy action sequence.
The craziest is the guy who directed it
was a fight coordinator apparently,
so he just had ideas for like the ideas
he'd never given people I think.
Oh.
And so he was like,
eh.
So we just saved it.
He needs a sandbag.
He must have worked for and then and
then unleashed.
It does not work with writers like
you're a writer.
Doesn't that work with writers
sometimes,
like if you see like,
like specific writers are writing for
someone else,
like a monologue or something like that.
I know what you're getting at.
No,
I mean like,
look,
I don't.
There are certain jokes that like if I'm
writing for like rock or something,
it's usually for like the bet awards,
so it's not like a.
It would have done that in my.
I would have done that topical joke
about usher in my.
The thing about monologues,
it's like pretty disposable,
but yeah,
I know I every now and then people on
snl that sucked as writers and then they
became cast members and all of a sudden
I hit a lot of good ideas.
They just store them all like squirrels.
Yeah.
Just like totally sandbag because comics
are like inherently kind of self
obsessed,
you know,
and the idea of like writing selflessly
for someone else and making them much
better.
I was talking to somebody about this
yesterday,
the fact that we,
it's an accepted thing in comedy that
it's just the accepted caste system that
rock is basically saying like,
Hey,
I'm funnier than you and I'm hosting
shelves.
So fucking Gimme jokes it based on what
the world saying.
I don't,
I don't think it's that explicit.
There is at the same time,
there's something flattering about the
fact that like,
one of the best comics wants me to run,
but it's a great um,
but there's also something about like,
you come here,
rub my back,
hey other MMA fighter,
come rub my back,
this fight.
I'm ranked higher than you.
So come around.
My bug was just like,
okay,
you can pay and all that stuff.
Think of it that way at all.
I think of it as,
first of all,
honestly,
I don't either.
I know you don't.
It's very intelligent for him because
it's the smart way to do it in a lot of
people don't do it that way.
They don't bring in other people to help
them and they're,
they're working kind of suffer,
you know,
like he's pretty smart in that way that
he's like looking at objects that
there's other strong people around.
If I bring them in,
it'll make my already strong act.
Even do it for his act.
He'll do it for a TV show monologue.
And uh,
and so it's not.
And the other thing with rock is it's
generally you write stuff for him.
And sent it to him so that he can be
confident in his shit.
Be like,
okay,
my shit's better than this.
Like fun.
Well you just need like a giant mound of
shit to chop away at.
And then you find where the gems are.
If you only have like a few,
like pretty decent ideas and you're
trying to build them up,
that's way,
way less effective than an enormous
catalog of ideas need to turn to present
x ones.
Yeah.
That's a rock.
Always says,
uh,
he's like,
I like,
I,
I have comedy writers around the way
rappers have gold chains.
Like that's all he spent his money on.
You know what I mean?
Like if he's gonna,
he's not gonna,
he's not gonna buy a chain.
He's like,
I'll just have a writer write for
fucking a movie with Marisa.
That's smart.
Yeah.
Well that's why he's Chris Rock.
He's got a,
you know,
as effective strategy for optimizing all
of his shows and all of the sets and
all,
you know,
he's,
he knows the fee on the thing that I
was.
When you were saying about having other
people come in.
Look,
I find that a lot of guys,
comedian wise,
when you get to the theater level,
um,
it's basically all your audiences are
henpecked.
All of your audiences are predisposed to
like you.
Do you ever scan?
What I found is a lot of people when
they go to theaters,
they're acting,
they're plateaus or gets worse.
Do you find,
do you ever specifically go to rooms
where they don't know you're coming to
get a better read on shit?
Yeah.
Well,
I do a lot of sets during the day,
like regular sets at the Improv or the
store where they're there to see,
have a wide variety of people.
I do a lot of those.
I think those are important,
I think sets at the store important
period because it's a fucking jaded
group down there.
It's beautiful and magical,
but it's jaded.
Yeah.
It's the hardest thing in the world.
Belly Room.
Yeah.
You might as well be doing standup for
one person.
One hundred percent.
People are right in front of the.
The worst part of the belly room is
there's people to the right that could
just charge the stage right there.
Fucking it.
Yeah.
Well it's also,
they have.
It's great though,
like what we're all were saying about
the thing,
like the worst part of it,
but even the worst part about it is
magic because that room is fucking
magic,
man.
That belly room,
if you get something to work and that
belly room.
We were talking about this last night,
that there's the belly room and the Ice
House and the Ice House is maybe the
best club ever.
It's got the rep and having done it,
it's like the easiest,
easiest.
Yeah.
Well let's just set up.
Perfect.
Yeah.
The ceiling is low.
Everyone's stuffed in there.
It's very contagious.
Laughter is great.
Acoustics saw wood everywhere.
The laughter really reverberates and
it's got whatever the fuck.
Fifty years of comedy burned into the
walls.
It's the oldest club in the country.
I think it's older than 50 years old,
isn't it?
I think that.
I think it's.
I think it is.
I think it's like 55 years old or
something like that,
but it's the irl.
It's essentially the oldest comedy club
on Earth because the oldest clubs for
comedy,
we're in America,
so the oldest one in America,
so it's the oldest,
longest running club ever,
so it's super rare place,
but it's way easier than like the Olr or
especially the belly room.
Different kind of Louis say in
an interview,
like when he does,
when he's in La,
he'll go,
he'll do like an alternative show.
Then he'll do the Improv or the laugh
factory and then he'll do the store and
it's like if it works,
he's like,
everything will work on alternative
room.
Some stuff will work at the Improv and
one thing will work at the store and the
one thing that works with the store that
keeps.
That's smart.
Yeah.
So you need all of those.
Because when I was just doing the store
only,
I think my ax suffered a little bit.
I think where does it go?
Because that's the thing.
It's hard to
the psychographic of the story.
You think they [inaudible] I still
couldn't tell you.
Having been working there six,
seven years,
I still couldn't tell you like the
psychology of that kind of part of the.
Of the average of the audience's
collective unconscious.
Well,
first of all,
let me just say this.
It's way better now.
The second,
my second run of the store from 2007 on.
I wasn't there,
so I started up again December 14.
It's way better.
It's just better.
It's a better club.
The young guys coming up are better.
There's a better vibe.
The audiences are better.
Yeah.
When I was there in the,
in the early two thousands,
man,
I was a war zone.
It was all old.
It was all old timers,
right?
I mean it was a lot of world,
but it was also.
The audience was just like monsters.
There was a lot of months like rapey dm
hat,
goalie,
drunky.
No crowd control at all.
They have real crowd control now.
They'll kick people out if they're
retarded.
Yeah.
They didn't use to do that.
They'll kick people out.
If they say eight things you have to
say.
You have to say,
fuck it.
Ate any of these gloves like,
no,
we're good.
It's fucking get them out.
They're not going to.
If they say more than one thing,
get them out.
They kicked the guy out at the ice house
last night and he like early on this one
bit,
he would cap yelling the same thing out
while the bit was going on and I
figured,
let me know Oregon.
Yeah,
we got to the end of the bay and he's
still yelling out the thing.
I'm like,
I heard you.
You Fuck?
And he's like,
well no,
I was talking about the thing on your
part because we're not having a
conversation is a fucking show.
Did he?
Keeps going.
I'm like,
Oh fucking Christ.
And then when the bouncers come over to
take him away,
he goes,
are you serious?
I was helping.
What do you think?
They just picked you.
They just randomly picked.
The guy decided to fuck with them.
That's what I said the other day to a
woman who was yelling.
I go,
you go to fucking Katy Perry concert,
sit at the bar at the bottom of the
stage and just sing along with her.
Shut the fuck up.
Like I don't need your help.
They didn't book the show and go those
four guys and then hopefully someone
will come and heckle them.
Yeah,
but a Katy Perry concert,
if you go and sit there and sing along
with her,
it's probably flatter area.
Yeah,
but if you're trying to,
if you're,
if you're at the foot of the stage doing
it,
it's probably the worst would be if you
were saying don't sing that song
precise.
Don't you have another song?
Which mayor was telling me the name drop
a was saying that the biggest issue at
his shows now girls running to the foot
of the stage,
turning their back to them and taking a
selfie.
Oh no,
he's at.
If he has security to like stop it.
It's like if I didn't stop it,
there'd be hundreds of people every year
and it's hugely distracting because
there's a thing starting at the thing
you're looking at.
Yeah.
Well,
don't you find distracting when you look
out into the crowd and you see like 10
phones up,
take the photos of you or taking a
selfie or taking picture with Neil
Brune.
She'll kill it at Hashtag.
Hashtag winning.
Hashtag tiger blood.
I mean there's so many people want to
take pictures now that Hannibal burress
did some weird thing at one of his shows
where they have some new technology.
It's like a pouch and they give you this
pouch,
close it.
And when you're inside the club the
pouch doesn't open so you can't get to
your phone.
So if your phone rings,
if you feel like you must answer it,
you have to leave the venue and then the
patch will open.
I guess it works on some sort of like a
frequency if you're past like one of
those electronic dog collars,
you know those things.
So it's something like that.
But man,
the reaction to it was like,
fuck you.
I was reading all the reaction,
although I tweeted it.
Yeah.
You know,
because I saw the store.
I'm like,
hmm,
this is kind of interesting.
I wonder how people feel about this.
Not that I would implement it,
I just,
I feel like the streisand effect is in
effect the streisand effect.
You know,
the,
the Barbara Streisand,
they found her house and they put her
house online like they,
you know,
like someone took a photo of it and like
this is where Barbara streisand's
houses.
And so she,
you know,
was offended.
She made this big deal and she's like,
fuck you take my house down,
this and that.
And because she put so much effort into
fighting the fact that our house was
down way more people knew about her
house and they all attacked and went
after her.
I think if you tell people she can't
bring your cell phone to my show,
then they start wearing.
Yeah,
they put a Gopro on,
are they,
you know,
they,
they'll film from a fucking one of those
glasses that has the lens in the sense
you had that at the tail down.
I had a guy google glasses,
uh,
google the laugh factory.
And I go,
dude,
I can't fucking.
Yeah.
I don't know if you're taping right?
So you're just being a dick because I,
you know,
I'm,
it's all I can think about now is this
fucking dude with the visor in my
peripheral vision and he might be,
he could be fucking periscoping it now
can use periscope from Google.
I think Google last might even be dead.
Do periscope the show.
I do periscope things,
but no,
not to show.
How come you want to.
Where I want to tweet about this by the
way.
Where should people go?
The show?
I already tweeted it out.
Just go to mine and retweet.
If you need to write you a bit addicted
to the.
No,
hold on.
Let me put that fucker and get it over
with Joseph Justa.
No,
no,
no.
I got it.
I got you are.
You are a commercial actor.
I know for a cell phone company and
you're addicted to cell phones.
Snake is interesting.
Eating the tail on around.
You need.
Alright,
great.
Why aren't you periscoping?
Alright,
I'll put you.
Pushed it away.
I love it.
It's out of range.
He's a haunting you right now.
That's out of range now.
Sometimes it haunts me.
I put my phone over there,
but,
but if there's something important
happening right now in the world of Van
to four wheel drive,
conversions are the,
uh,
the cell phone thing.
Someone was telling me when you go again
and I don't.
This isn't my name.
Drop when you go to drake's house.
When girls come over [inaudible] he
makes everyone turned their cell phones.
It really?
Yeah.
Smart.
Because they kind of want to take a
picture of course.
Um,
yeah.
And it's just like,
no,
you can't do it.
So he makes him like put it in a bucket
or something.
I don't.
Yeah.
I don't know the specifics of it,
but it's good move.
Yeah.
Shovel Vault smart.
Safe.
Put your phone.
That is what is.
Why is the table in the vault?
That's where your phone goes.
What?
Everybody puts her phone and want to say
you want to say yes.
No,
no phones.
No phones baby.
Um,
yeah.
How are we going to take selfie?
Drake,
drake.
I got it baby.
I got it.
Well,
you have to have,
if you're like one of those big time
baller rapper characters and trying to
keep everything on the dl or at least
keep as much of your private life
private as possible.
You've got to take like some serious
precautionary steps.
Yeah,
I've heard of guys like having prenups
are not prenups,
but nondisclosure.
Nondisclosure.
Oh yeah.
Every.
I mean not everybody,
but like that's a common thing.
Like I've done things where like you
can't even be in the bedroom with the
person until you've signed an NDA.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well if you're worried about a fake rape
accusation,
that's the way to deal with it.
One hundred percent.
But then the girl could say,
well,
I was
thinking we're going to make out and as
soon as I signed it,
he just started raping.
Yeah.
And then it's like,
well,
yeah,
but you said you wouldn't say,
well look here today I'm going to tough
spot.
Because you said,
yeah,
you just,
I think they assume like once I sign
this,
you're not,
like all bets are off,
but I think they just assume.
I don't know man.
I would think that,
yeah,
I guess if you're Michael Jordan though.
Yeah.
What do you do?
You know what I mean?
Like what do you.
You have to.
Well those guys,
when you're worth as much money as a guy
like Michael Jordan,
you become not just a human being,
but an opportunity.
Yeah.
Like a multinational corporation.
Walking around and appealing the slip
and fall accidents and charge you with
it.
Oh,
absolutely.
Completely.
One hundred percent.
Right.
You've got to think that that is a.
he's a target in that sense.
Whereas if you're worth that kind of
money,
people look at you and they go,
look,
if I sue this motherfucker for
$100,000,000,
if things go badly,
I got five.
Yeah.
I mean like you only give me half a
million dollars just to shut the fuck up
and then boom,
you're out the door with a half a
million bucks and you know,
nothing really even happened to you and
there's a bunch of people that do that
over and over and over,
over and over.
Jordan probably get sued everyday.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Between the corporation and the,
just every like there's.
Yeah.
Wow.
Not fucked.
Yeah.
I was reading about this one guy who was
involved.
I forget what the case,
but um,
it turned out that he had sued like
dozens and dozens of people for like
he's a professional lawsuit litigate or,
or a lawsuit claiming.
Yeah,
whatever the fuck it is.
Some shit and this guy just does that.
It goes from one to the next tries to
figure out how to make some money and
then susie this guy and then Suzanne guy
for fraud and this guy for front,
like,
you know,
that's a creepy,
creepy abuse.
There's a music company like that that
just will go after the slightest
infraction real.
And they,
they,
they're,
they're like,
they're known in the music industry.
They will sue you.
It's like commodore music or some shit
and they'll just go after fucking the
slightest.
It kind of sounds like this,
that in and it holds people up and
people to settle.
Well every now and then when one does
get through,
like that song that was like blurred
lines.
Yeah.
Well Marvin Gaye.
Yeah,
I mean that is exactly like,
how the fuck did they not know that
people are going to see that?
I think there's so much copying and the
music business that I think they were
just like,
it's just kind of like somewhat sounds,
just like fucking that song,
you know,
what I was listening to,
there was a,
I was listening to a podcast,
the camera,
what it was they would,
but they were playing Bob Dylan songs
that were stolen that,
that deal install wives because he was
doing all folk songs so it was all sort
of public domain,
but he was taking other people's
melodies and then making them,
changing the lyrics and those became
hits for him.
Yeah,
it was,
I was,
blew my mind because you've got bob bill
involve people.
It's like the,
you know,
the poet laureate of the fucking the
most,
etc.
Yeah.
Just as much as anYbody else.
George harrison got sued for um,
two different songs was my avatar was
not one of them.
Uh,
if they were both hits,
one was like,
I'd like to teach the world to sing.
I think he did it one that I think coke
did it before him and then he did
something that sounded like and lost
that I believe I could be wrong,
but I like to buy the world a coke.
Yeah.
That was before.
I'd like to teach the world to say no.
I,
uh,
no.
It's the same song.
Oh,
I don't know what george harrison's was,
but I know that he lost two lawsuits,
but to thin lines one after all the
different lawsuits and all the different
people that have been sued for stealing
lines in,
in songs or stealing melodies,
you would think that they wouldn't think
that they could pull that off.
Yeah.
I was surprised that one,
to be honest with you,
because.
Yeah,
I was surprised that one because it's.
You could make a case.
It's different enough.
Really.
Okay.
It's not the same.
It's not the same tempo.
Oh,
okay.
Maybe I was wrong.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Need listen to it.
I know they did another one.
They tried to go after him for another
marvin gaye song.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
That one's like much more shaky than
this one,
but for ells,
a creative guy,
so it's not like they're dealing with
some hack and he wrote the whole thing.
Is it possible to frozen a little bit of
a hack a look?
Anything's possible.
Anything is anything.
I mean,
yeah,
he's a.
I'm sure everyone's a little bit of a
hack I guess,
but like bob dylan's,
a little bit of a hack.
Precisely.
None of us are safe.
If bill cosby's raping,
what chance did the rest of us have?
Does that the biggest shock that you've
ever heard in all my years of.
No.
You know why?
Because I met him 20 years ago and he
was a fucking dick and when his show
started the sitcom,
I was like,
I don't like that guy.
Really.
I promise you.
As a 10 year old,
I was like,
I don't like that guy.
It's Just a fucking ego maniac.
I knew it from the mit.
I mean,
I'm rarely that write about something.
Rarely do I not like someone and they
turn out to be like a serial rapist,
but usually you're just kind of a dick,
but to become a c,
I was like,
yeah,
that totally makes sense for you.
Ever made it,
met him.
You had this,
you had,
you'd made them?
Yeah.
Figured it out.
Didn't like,
didn't never liked the sitcom.
Thought i was crazy.
Really?
Yeah.
When I went to college,
nyu,
there was an essay in some english lit
book,
say explaining what the formula for the
show was,
which was um,
the kids have an original idea,
a,
an original design and original idea.
And then bill cosby spends the episode
chopping them down and it was like,
yeah,
that's exactly what every episode was.
And I hated it just as a kid.
I'm like,
fuck this guY,
fuck them.
Let them have a bug and lead to let a
ruby or whatever the rudy,
have a fucking let her get a pet or
whatever.
Whatever she wanted.
So you met him?
Yeah.
And how lonG after you saw the show did
you meet him?
I met him in 1993 at,
uh,
the arsenio hall show,
the original.
Really?
YeaH.
and so this would,
do we know each other then?
Yeah,
it was after.
I mean,
we hadn't seen it but it was like after
I was a doorman down here and went to
and met the woman who works at the
arcenio and through dave and whatever.
So she was like,
and whenever there's somebody cool
launch,
it's like come and meet someone.
So met him and he was talking about
slavery and he was like,
it was me,
him and two black dudes and he goes,
he,
he because he goes.
And then the dutch man came and pointed
at me and I was like,
I'm not dutch,
but he was like,
you know,
close enough.
But the fact that he would point them in
because we're not,
you know,
I'm not,
what are the odds?
I'm fucking dutch.
And the fact that he just pointed at me
and was any.
He's a predator like wildly smug guy.
Wildly smug.
Yeah.
Huh.
I'm like,
you know,
smart guy.
But not as.
He's one of those guys will talk and
then say in other words,
four times.
It's like,
no,
you're making the same point for them.
Like I got it the first time.
Right.
To impress themselves.
Yeah.
In my experience.
Smart.
Like really smart people at god damn it.
w w,
what are we doing here with wrestling?
And we having a conversation like,
what are we doing?
Well they're not,
you're not there.
Yeah,
you don't.
It doesn't matter who they're talking
to.
You're just a warm.
You're just like,
uh,
if they're the predator,
you're just like fucking red.
Like you're just a thing that they're
talking at.
Yeah.
And the heat signature.
You're,
you're a walking heats so they just
fucking die.
I.
Well that to me was the only thing that
made sense about this.
It's like how could someone drugs,
somebody like that.
And I've thought about and I was like,
I bet if you have lived decade after
decade of people just kissing her ass
and everyone around you is like some
weird form of a yes man.
Like you have a whole industry behind
you.
Like,
but he's on the show,
like think about he has all the
production assistants and the producers
and the executive producers and the
cameraman and the sound guys and the
makeup people and everyone is just,
yeah,
mr cosby and that's your existence and
you get onstage in front of that crowd
and you're making this show and he's
american killer comedian.
He's a fUcking killer.
I don't like the guy.
And I'm saying he's,
he's a killer.
And think that you just developed this
sort of like really distorted,
psychotic view
of yourself in relationship to the rest
of the world?
I don't think so because he's the first
famous person that's,
I think he had the pathology before.
He was famous.
the idea that I've never heard of a
famous person like,
oh yeah,
so my shit now is I got to the drug
bitches in and rape them when they're
asleep level.
Like that's not a level that's not like
a known itself.
So I think it was the thing that he had
a.
In some ways I don't feel bad for them,
but what do you do you know,
any sexual desire you have,
you're eventually going to do.
You can quell it for four nights.
So you say like if you have that,
what do you do?
Kind of creepy.
Like there was a this american life
about a guy who was a pedophile.
He was 19,
he was a pedophile.
One of the had sexual feelings for like
10,
12 year old boys hadn't acted on It and
it's like,
what do I do?
Jesus christ.
What do you do?
That's why when people go so and so like
prostitutes,
whatever.
It's like a transvestite,
It's like poor him.
Like in some ways it's like you're gonna
your dick makes you do awful shit.
So I believe he had that before.
Before he was famous or anything I was.
I don't think it's.
Yeah,
I wonder if that part is
that this was a more commonly accepted
practice because he had a bit that he
used to do about.
Yeah.
I wonder if like people didn't think
that it was that big of a deal or as big
of a deal as they think of now,
like maybe people didn't think of
hitting someone with a mickey that's
called.
They had a cute lIttle name for it.
Whereas now it's like drug raids.
Yeah.
You know?
To me that spanish fly argument was a.
That just sounded like one of those,
remember back in the day,
but it's like remember speaking spell.
It's like one of those bits for
regeneration.
Um,
but yeah,
I think it was way more like there was,
I was reading about the,
one of the girls who lived at hugh
hefner's house and he offered her a loot
and saId back in the old days they used
to call these lego openers or thigh
openers.
And it's just like,
I believe it.
I believe that they use vitamins.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
women even 30 years ago didn't have a
lot of rights,
like sexual harassment.
I don't think the first sexual
harassment suit was tilt if I'm at the
earliest.
It was the late seventies.
It's amazing how much things have
changed.
And how quickly things have changed,
we were reading yesterday on the podcast
was yesterday,
day before yesterday,
this speech by lincoln when he was
debating like 18,
58 to be debating the rights of black
people.
And even lincoln back then was saying
that he didn't think that they should be
allowed to serve on juries or vote or
even intermarry with whites.
And it was like,
whoa,
like that's not that long ago.
I thought that there were four fifths of
a person.
Like you're
not,
you're not,
you're not three fifths,
but you're not fun either.
And you know,
the argument is,
well listen,
you have to put it into context like his
time during his time,
this was revolutionary.
That was progressive,
who's incredibly progressive.
Yeah.
It's not that long ago,
man,
so long ago at all.
That's done even 200 years ago.
What's cool is that peer that we're
living in now as you can get rights.
I mean this shit is like the gay rights
movement and the trans,
right?
I mean that.
I've never seen a movement like this.
Them get traction writes things amazing.
Yeah.
They're starting to get gay marriage all
over the country.
It's like popping up pop,
pop,
pop.
It's,
it's a cause.
It was stupid anyway,
but first of all,
let's be honest.
Marriage is pretty fucking stupid.
Retarded.
This is coming from a married person.
Yeah.
The idea of like you're going to sign a
contract.
Some of based on romance.
Yeah.
like,
you know,
I get it,
I get that you'd want,
you'd want some sort of security,
but if you're gay and you can't even
make.
People can't even get pregnant unless
you guys figure out how to eat.
You have to get a surrogate or you're
talkIng about,
you know,
maybe friends that are also lesbians
that want a kid.
And like I'll tell you will have two
kIds.
You give me one and ultimately with the
how do you work it out,
but they're going to be your kids.
But yeah.
But that wasn't about that.
It was about like you also couldn't
visit.
You're over the hump so you couldn't,
you couldn't get insurance rights,
all that stuff.
No.
Look,
even if you don't want to get married,
it's a,
it's a quality.
You know you want to be able to do,
you don't want to fucking law that says
you can't imagine.
Can't marry another man that he loves.
That's gross and stupid and the fact
that that was common until really
recently and the argument,
because it aIn't writing well,
that's not a fucking art.
It ain't right.
It's not a legal argument.
Still been going on today.
These guys that are running for
republican office,
it's still happening today.
You know what I mean?
Rick santorum was just talking about it
recently.
All these fucking dummies.
what does that guy.
I'm ted cruz.
That fucking dumb.
He doesn't believe in it.
I'm just going to lose like you fucking
dumb ass.
There's enough people that that cleaned
to that stupidity that are still on
their side for now.
They're like the last fucking
confederate flag holdouts and is it is
there or is there not something in the
bible about it because I've heard some
men are not supposed to lie down with
men and it's an abomination.
That's what it saYs,
but it says who you're dealing with.
MulTiple translations was to go,
yeah.
Well,
not only that,
there's more than 2000 years ago,
the oldest versions of the bible that we
know of today are the dead sea scrolls
and the dead sea scrolls,
the only bible,
only version of the bible that's an
aramaic,
and when they try to translate it,
like if the stories are similar but
different,
so all sorts of wacky shit in the dead
sea scrolls that isn't in any of the
other books.
I knew the religious texts and then you
go to the oldest versions of the bible
is all in ancient hebrew.
Little fuck speaks ancient hebrew.
You've got to translate that to latin
and they translated that to greek and a
lot of shit gets missing in the process.
When they wrote ancient hebrew to
ancient hebrew letters and numbers were
interchangeable,
like words had numerical value to them,
like there was no number.
So the letter a was also the number one.
Yeah,
so it's just such a different context is
different.
There's a different meaning to
everything they were saying like the
word god and the word love.
They have the same numerical value and
numerical values are actually important
in the.
When you're saying a sentence,
you know,
you say a sentence,
there's tone,
there's sarcasm there so you can see
things in it.
That's why textIng is hard to exactly.
Are you mad at me like no man,
we were fucking around.
You know,
sometimes people don't know I'm mad at
you,
but in,
in ancient hebrew apparently it's hard
for us to put it in perspective and kind
of understand the way they communicated,
but when they wrote things down,
there was inherent new miracle quality
to the census.
They had lIke a,
some,
it was worth the sentence,
had numbers to it and I don't think
we're.
There are 50 arguments against why the
bible is real and there's one pro
argument which is I like it.
It makes me feel good.
That's the only argument you can give.
Well,
the idea that gOd would write one book a
long time ago to one dude and then go
off to manage grasshopper populations
and make sure her gains happen.
Like,
where have you been man?
How come you don't tell us agaIn?
don't you understand there's 30
different versions of this?
Wouldn't you want to carry it up?
Yeah,
you're a dick at this point.
Like if you made a quote like if you,
if there was a controversial issue that
came up,
you know,
and you made a quote and then a bunch of
people took that quote and butchered it
and twisted it up 15 different ways to
sunday and you are aware of it,
wouldn't you want to correct that when
you want to come back and Go,
whoa,
I didn't see you have to eat babies that
are the color of orange.
THat is not what I said.
Like you guys are.
You guys fucked the whole thing up.
Yeah.
But not this god guy.
He's like,
I told you.
Yeah,
Yeah.
I told you once I'm not and I'm not
going to tell you again.
What did all these people that are lying
about what you said?
You got to figure out.
It's not my fault.
Not my problem.
It's not my game,
bro.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah,
it's a.
There's so you believe in a god.
I don't not believe,
you know,
I think it would be super arrogant to
say,
I don't believe in god.
I've seen so many things on psychedelic
drugs that don't make any sense at all.
Then I'm like,
how?
Why would I ever be so cocky as to think
that I have the whole framework of the
universe spelled out?
It's purely speculation.
Even for scientists like for scientists
and scientists are studying the very
nature of matter itself down to
subatomic particles and quasars and
supernovas and gas clouds and all these
different things that they're studying.
At the end of the day,
all they are really,
truly aware of is what they can perceive
their own senses in this existence.
They don't know what happens when you
die.
They don't know if it's just a gateway
to another new completely different kind
of experience.
They don't know,
and the idea that it's not that it's
just death and it's black and darkness.
well,
where did you come from in the first
place?
Why are you even here?
Why are you even here as a conscious
entity?
Like why is the idea of you,
you thinking about you?
that is a real thing,
like what purpose does it serve and why
is it,
why does it exist and is it possible
that this whole thing is just a long
process,
sort of like a seed goes into the
ground,
water gets on that seed,
this seed sprouts pops through the
ground becomes a tree,
the tree gives fruit,
the fruit drops,
fruit that fruit goes into the ground,
becomes new trees.
Animals eat those treats or nutrients
for the next generation part of this
weird,
crazy ecosystem and the ecosystem that
has that has created a human being with
all their creativity and self awareness
and all their ability to reflect and
change and this crazy desire for
innovation like to have the newest,
greatest shit.
The biggest,
coolest thing,
the fastest thing,
the smartest thing,
the most advanced thing.
We're constantly searching for this
newer,
better product.
It would seem to me that all of that is
a part of some almost inescapable
process of change,
change and improvement and change.
It seems like the whole thing is always
changing,
right?
Like a cloud forms or rather a planet
forms out of clouds and dust and all
kinds of shit and eventually turns into
a planet eventually acquires water,
eventually has an atmosphere and then
life comes out of it in that life
spreads out into other planets and all
of it seems to be this constant state of
either improvement or death improvement
and death improvement in death and to
say that it's not building towards
something.
It's like,
how the fuck do you know?
How do you know?
I mean,
we literally might be building towards
heaven and if human beings with all of
our interest in trans rights and gay
rights and being progressive,
I really contemplate this a lot.
I think about this all day.
I wonder if what we're doing by this
movement that you say what's like,
some of it's exaggerated and ridiculous
and some.
Some of the people that are involved in
it are ultimately really shitty people
that have attached themselves to an
interesting idea,
but the trend seems to be inescapable
and the trend of technological
innovation as well as a trend of social
awareness.
They might,
if you extrapolate,
you look at where they're going,
like a thousand years now,
100,000
years now,
it might reach a point of really like a
technologically created heaven.
It is totally possible,
a technologically creative having
created by human beings.
It's created by whatever the fuck fuels
a human being.
We will look at it as us like human
beings.
We did it,
but what is the what?
The what is a human being?
I mean there's a bunch of different
instincts and a bunch of different
desires that are sort of sown into the
existence of being a person and they're
unacceptable,
inexorable,
you know,
you have them.
If you're living in the jungle,
If you're living in the city you have.
I mean people just have this weird,
inescapable desire to do a bunch of core
things.
Well,
maybe those core things are very
important and key ingredients towards
creating technology and towards creating
awareness and connection of ideas and
information from entity to entity until
the the entire thing.
Thanks as one to the entire thing thinks
is one and has massive technological
capabilities and literally can escape
the very dimension that is currently
trapped in the dimension that it thinks
is all that there is.
This is all that there is because I can
knock on it with my knuckles and I could
put it on a scale and I could run a tape
measure by and tell you exactly how long
it is.
So that's what is real,
but that's not even what's real.
That's what's real right now that you
can experience and we might be a part of
one continual never ending cycle that
ultimately leads to god.
Yeah.
Possible.
That's the thing I don't find to say you
don't say I don't believe.
No,
I don't think so either.
I don't think.
Well,
I think it's arrogant to say,
you know,
there's no go,
oh yeah.
I don't think anyone knows.
There's no good,
but say I don't believe in god.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
I don't believe in god either,
but I don't not believe in god.
Right.
Zero.
God,
I dunno.
Yeah.
I've met some crazy shit and psychedelic
trips.
You know,
I've,
I've had a couple of examples if you
can.
Well,
I'm things that knew everything that
I've ever done,
everything that I've ever said and who I
was exactly down to the core thing.
What do you mean things?
Entities,
they're can see right through you now.
What are those entities or this trip or
this,
this is like you meet this guy and he
knows everything.
Well you're,
you're not meeting a guy.
You're meeting like a geometric pattern
that is like you can't.
Especially dmt trips.
You can't really isolate what something
looks like because it only looks like
that for the briefest of moments and
then it changes and looks like something
else and it changes and as you think
about what it is it alters and it's
almost like some bizarre lesson in
perception and the and your own
definitions of the world around you that
you are in some way.
BY the way,
you interface with the world changing
the very nature of the world itself and
this is like some weird lesson that they
try to teach you while you're.
WhIle you're involved in these trips,
it seems like they're trying to explain
to you there's.
It's not just you have a bad attitude or
not just anybody has a bad attitude.
It's not just that you go,
you get tied up in the momentum of those
bad attitudes and the mistakes caused by
those bad attitudes and the energy
that's put out and the ripple effect of
all that energy and how's it,
how it goes out into the rest of the
population and how it comes back to you
and you get trapped like a goddamn
spiderweb and explains it to you.
That literally the way that you
interface with the world changes the
world,
changes your world,
changes the people that are in your
world,
but also changes how those people
interact with other people in the world
as this very freaky fucking bizarre
thing to have that be told to you by
gestures like giant,
like gestures who have like
multidimensional head that's like
spinning around and giving me the finger
and.
But I would say that's just your own,
your own consciousness.
It may be that as a person,
it may be,
or an entity or a wall or whatever.
It's totally possible.
We don't know what your own
consciousness really means.
Yeah,
I mean,
first of all,
look,
a human being is not an individual.
Every human being is a host of an
unknown variable.
I mean like literally an uncountable
number of bugs,
like the amount of parasites and the
amount of different bacteria.
They say there's more cola in a person's
body than there have ever been people
ever.
So think of that.
Does this what?
Just to just to stop and think about and
you need that.
If that's not in your body,
you're fucked some shit.
Like the fact that we even know what he
call is like,
science is fucking like the last 70,
80 years.
It's just like,
what?
Yeah,
how,
what,
how to do even the fuck did you get
what?
I had Brian Cox on the professor who's
brilliant guy who works at cern,
who works at the large hadron collider.
And he was trying to explain to the,
you know,
searching for the hadron in searching
for the,
um,
the higgs boson particle and it halfway
into the conversation like,
where,
why,
how did you guys find this out?
Who did,
what did you do?
You know,
we're just a couple of hundred years
away from a guy making fire with steel
and flint.
That's the onlY way they made fire
clink,
clink.
That's how they had to make fire.
And you guys have figured this out.
Yeah.
What the fuck,
man?
Yeah,
It's a,
it's an,
it's unbelievable.
It's really hard to believe.
Yeah.
Very,
very,
very hard to wrap your head around.
What are they going at with the higgs
boson,
by them?
What are they trying to figure out?
What will that lead to while they're
trying to recreate?
And they,
they have apparently recreated the
conditions milliseconds after the big
bang and prove that there is this one
particle that was theoretical up until
recently and they've measured it there
like 99 point nine percent sure that
they've isolated this particle and
measured it.
but along the way they've also,
they've also identified a bunch of other
shit that they weren't sure if it was
real or or created some things that were
just theoretical.
One is this stuff called clark cork glue
on cork glue on plasma that's insanely
heavy.
Like if You had a bowling ball full of
this stuff,
it'd be heavier than the world.
Yeah.
And they've figured out how to isolate
that.
And it's also the same sort of thing.
It's something that exists like
milliseconds after the big bang.
It's like a part of the very creation of
the universe itself.
So there won't necessarily be like.
And if this is then
we'll then all get the floating
skateboard.
You see the floating skateboard
yesterday did of unbelievable.
But I'll pull up.
What's funny is how long it took me to
get used to it though.
I'm like,
oh good,
there's a floating skateboard and I
like.
And you just go back to your dumb life.
You're not like,
oh fuck,
we got to get good.
Okay.
Yeah.
It'll be totally normal.
I mean a car is fucking insane.
If you didn't have a car and somebody
gave you a car,
is this it?
Lexus has created a real rideable
hoverboard.
Okay.
So here's a guy with a skateboard and he
gets off and he stamps on it says there
is no such thing as impossible and he's
smoking.
I don't like the smoke.
I think that's a,
that's an after effect.
And I think it's stupid.
Uh,
I thought it's the best part of this ad.
Put it.
This guy is never going to smoke.
It's just a matter of figuring out how.
So he's going to stand on this now.
Lexis hoveR the not showing you any more
than that.
That's the tease.
You fucks.
That's it.
You got to see this new rx though.
This thing.
What is it?
I'm just kidding.
I'm a big fan of alexis's.
Yeah.
Japanese engineering.
It's a little slightly different than
the german engineering.
All Of it's pretty fucking bad ass
though.
Did you have the 400 damn whatsapp video
of the,
the,
like the 400 x.
That one.
The alexIs?
No,
I have,
uh,
s suv.
the lx five slash 70.
Oh,
why the rx?
400.
Sorry.
Yeah,
they're fucking amazing.
Driving living room.
Yeah,
it's smooth as fuck y'all.
Yeah.
It's so fun.
Floaty floats down the highway.
They make amazing automobiles.
If you think about the fact that the
automobile has only been around for a
little over 100 years to the amount of
innovation that's happened with that.
Yeah,
and that's when It's in maths.
Even retarded by other industries like
it should be further along.
Well,
I think with this tesla shit like this
elon musk character getting involved,
that guy's making an suv now that's
going to be an all electric.
He's making a two door also.
He's making a bunch of shit,
but the fact that bigger thing that he
did was he.
He like,
he basically gave up all his patents
here.
Just let's make it good.
Let's make this an actual thing.
Well,
he's like a real life tOny stark type
character.
Yeah.
He's got that new thing for the wall to
new battery system for,
for solar.
For houses.
Yeah.
Because you can't get the thing that I
didn't realize about solar.
She can't get.
He can't get it at night unless you
store it.
Yeah,
you can't.
It's really,
really hard to store.
Well,
most of the time you have these solar
rooms.
Like a,
there was a cabin a that a friend of
mine has in Colorado and she's got these
uh,
like solar batteries hooked up to the
cabin and you know,
it's like a room.
Y'all gotta go into the battery rooM,
see what's going on.
And the batteries were dead.
It was fucking awful.
But it was a real problem.
The guy who was staying in the cabinet,
I was like,
what the fuck?
No,
fuck them lights,
you know,
stupid.
We're camping here.
Yeah.
It just wasn't working correctly.
But with this ian Must thing.
Elon musk's is very small.
It's not that big.
It's like a half about this guy and like
half the table.
LIke a small coffee table.
Yeah.
And you can put it on the wall.
Can you put it on the wall?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what it's for.
Power wall.
Yeah.
See how it's got.
It's up there at mounts to the wall.
It's cool to home battery.
That charges using electricity generated
from solar panels or when utility rates
are low and powers your home in the
evening,
it also fortifies your home against
power outages by providing a backup.
Electricity supply.
Provable.
That's goiNg to.
I have a volt.
I was going to get a tesla and I got the
chevy volt because someone pointed out
what if there's a power outage?
Yep.
That'll do it.
Yeah.
The volt takes both,
right?
Is that the deal?
no,
the volt.
Yeah.
The volt takes both it.
I can go to gas when the revolution
comes.
I can.
That's a smart move right now.
You've got your feet in both worlds.
A little bit of both.
Joe,
do you,
when you put it up with gas,
does it charge the battery?
No,
it basically you get 40 miles of
electric,
just sure electric.
Yeah,
and then once you.
That's pretty stupid.
I'm being honest.
What do you mean not enough?
The average person drives 36 miles a
day,
but what about those extra four miles
and you'd go to get a sandwich and
throw,
which is a drip.
A gas station were cast out.
Oh,
you're telling me when the revolution
comes?
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know what to tell you.
You better have a power wall.
you got to have one of them yellow.
Elon musk.
Yeah.
But even then it's probably.
Although no,
if you have the solar,
well solar is only going to work as long
as the fucking weather stays exactly the
same.
If you have solar and you live in a
place like columbus,
Ohio in the winter,
good luck.
Fuck face.
Yeah.
You're not going to get much power
unless they develop some sort of new
shit.
BuT if your skies are gray,
like where I grew up in boston winters,
all gray,
everything's gray.
You're not gonna met and put maybe those
new ones actually,
they're better.
They got to be getting better with
overcast shit,
but it's not like being out in the
desert,
palm springs,
no shit like that.
We could just power the whole world from
it.
Yeah.
Hopefully that'll happen in the next 15,
20 years.
What's amazing when you look at la,
I mean the one resource that we have in
abundance is sunshine.
I mean that is the,
our research really nothing with it very
little because we don't have to because
the dwp has a monopoly.
Are you worried about the water?
Yes.
Yeah,
me too.
How could you not be like,
I don't know what's going to happen?
Well,
we're not going to have much water.
Yeah,
that's going to happen.
So that's a new normal thing now.
Like essentially we're a,
we're a giant desert city and they're
going to try actually admitting what
were like,
no.
Yeah,
well we're a desert city that had
intermittent rainfall,
but the reason why la was created in the
first place as a hollywood,
as a movie production place was because
it was so consistent with its winter.
That's the whole meat.
That means you live in a place that
sucks.
I mean,
it's great for the sun,
but it's.
Yeah,
it's not good for life.
Well
yet.
We're not supposed to be here.
Yeah,
it's not.
It's not inhabitable unless you do a lot
of shit,
unless you'd like.
We're going to reroute the Colorado.
It's just like,
dude,
Maybe we just just stay near the
Colorado river.
Well,
what's interestinG is with climate
change,
one of the things I'm keeping an eye on
iS what happens to seattle's,
whether,
because I have a buddy who just moved up
to seattle theory about that.
Yeah.
And he fucking said this.
Winter was amazing.
He was like,
dude,
it barely reined.
It wasn't that clOudy.
It was wonderful and he was coming from
brooklyn.
I think seattle,
portland and seattle become la and
vancouver becomes san francisco too.
I like the way you think.
Yeah,
I think that's in like 50 years,
you're probably dead,
right?
You're dead,
I'm a big five.
Seattle getting property in vancouver a
bunch.
You feel like I'm really.
I'm really done.
The race are very expensive.
Real esTate in vancouver.
Yes.
But a lot of beautiful asian girls.
Oh shit.
Someone is thinking,
well,
they're great canadians.
First of all,
canadian girls to just.
They're just,
they're reasonable.
Yeah,
they're more chill.
They're fun.
They're more fun.
Yeah,
they're less.
Uh,
I found they've been less.
Jay.
You did.
They're less.
I don't know,
the hottest girls.
I have a better chance with hot age and
a hot canadian girls than I do with hud.
American girls.
Hmm.
Like the hottest girls I've dated.
Generally.
We're canadian.
Really?
Yeah.
You think they're less worried about
looks and more worried about.
I think they're just more.
They actually like care if you're nice
and cool and chill and decent.
Well their whole culture is just so
different because it didn't come from
this marauding take over the world.
sort of a mentality that the,
the United States,
as you know in the United States has
this leader of the world go fuck
yourself.
America free.
toby keith.
You know they don't.
They don't have that up in Canada.
they don't have any of that.
I lot of times I think like the military
industrial complex is just because we
have the bumps.
It's like,
well,
we got the bumps.
It's like we got the avocados,
we gotta make some fucking guacamole,
man.
We fucking paid for the bumps.
It's fucking use these things.
We'll talk about a cycle.
That's the cycle.
It's like you can't not extract that
money.
The people that are making bombs and the
people that are involved in the and they
can't not do that.
If they see that they're not going to
stop,
it's too much money.
They're not going to stop asking.
We just have to stop giving it to them.
What do you make of the thing of like?
Well,
the thing of light lost jobs because
that,
that's not an argument to me.
Lost jobs from the military industrial
complex.
Like we ain't got away.
We're going to,
man,
I got 8,000
people in my district and all that shit.
It's like,
well,
fucking having to do something else.
Same thing with coal.
They say that about coal industry.
They said about horseshoes.
Yeah,
exactly.
precisely.
It's like,
well,
what about the blacksmiths?
Yeah.
He put in a lot of black students at
your fancy fucking fancy car.
Well,
that's the other thing is when computers
and robots take over,
there
will be blue collar people breaking into
factories to beat up the robots.
Probably.
They really go in the sledge hammers and
they'll start,
which I believe is the,
uh,
is the definition of a,
a what a luddite is,
are people that were so anti.
Yes.
Robot that they beat them up.
They beat machines up.
Right.
It wasn't really.
Was so fucking wrong.
Yeah.
they're not wrong.
That was,
that was like during the industrial age,
right?
Look at this member of any bands of
english workers who destroyed machinery,
especially in cotton and woolen mills
and they believe with threatening their
jobs in 18,
11 to 18,
60.
That will be,
that will be a he,
I believe that will be a huge thing.
Yeah.
It's like.
But stan hopes you ever hear stainless
bit about like should,
where they're like,
oh,
it's only a five percent unemployment.
It's like,
shouldn't we be going for hundred
percent unemployment?
Like don't we all just not want to work?
Like why are we going toward this
fucking dumb work thing when we could
just.
Why don't we all figure it out?
So we'd.
none of us have to work because people
have associated working with making
money and making money with staying
alive and the only way you can
contribute as if you work and the only
way you can get money to stay alive as
if you were in this.
The one thing that everybody's worried
about,
right?
Everybody's worried about not being able
to pay their bills and starving to
death.
Yeah.
HavIng their children go hungry and
like,
fuck,
what if we.
What if we live like the places that we
know exist all over the world and this
place is all over the world where
children go hungry.
Well,
there's also that protestant work ethic
thing where it's like it's next to
godliness.
It becomes one,
two gods smiled.
You know what I mean?
Like when the man work,
like that's a huge tenant.
Well don't you think that that's one of
those,
those tenants that those existed because
they were trying to instill this idea of
you have to stay alive and so it's good
to,
to work hard.
It's nobody wants to fucking farm and
plow the fields,
but if you don't do it,
we're all going to fucking star,
so let's make it a religious ethic.
Let's make it a super important thing to
god really likes and when you plow,
god loves it.
When you plant seeds,
sow the seed.
Go do it.
Yeah,
I'd loves it.
Is it even possible to have,
would that be possible to have it 100
percent unemployment?
You know like could society.
Society is based on bartering and
trading and.
Yeah,
and there's also work that people like
to do.
What about that?
What if you're a dentist and you enjoy
doing dentistry?
You want 100 percent employment
placement and I have all these clients.
I enjoy fixing their teeth.
What's the fucking robots,
bro?
I went to school for it.
I'm fascinated.
I got robots though,
but you didn't go to school,
but you didn't go to school.
You didn't have people that are car
enthusiasts that fix cars.
What about people that make clothes that
are really into designing clothes?
I you still do it,
but the idea that you have to do it to
survive,
I think it's just an intro.
I don't disagree with them.
Hmm.
Like that you'd want someone in this
robot's someone would have to make the
robots.
Right.
That's work,
but at some point someone's going to
have to work in the robots.
Even if there's robots making robots,
someone has to serve as the superhero.
You know what I mean?
Like so someone's going to have to work
and then that guy is going to want shit
for the work he did and then it just
becomes a bartering society.
It doesn't seem like it's ever possible
to go to 100 percent,
but you might be able to get down to
like 10 percent plus robots.
Yeah.
If you get down to 10 percent working 90
percent,
that's an imposing sentence by blank
blank plus robots.
Yeah.
Because once you've got robots in the
mix,
everything changes.
You don't need a whole lot of people to
run the robot because you get robots
that fix robots and the robots to fix
the robot,
to fix the robots.
Who watches the watch with water?
That is robots.
The robots.
I mean you would have to make sure that
also that the people that did do all the
work were they,
that you kept a steady supply of them
and kept them educated because if you
didn't and then we ran out of people
that knew how to fix the robots and then
we're just scrambling like we have to
relearn how to fix robots.
There was a book,
I think it was a white noise,
don delillo,
but it talked about like,
I couldn't fucking fix a clock.
I couldn't fix it.
I couldn't fix the light.
I couldn't fix any if something.
Like if I was the last guy,
like I couldn't fix shit at all.
We know how to hold bit about that,
about dumb people like not realizing
they're dumb because they buy a lot of
smart things that other people figured
out.
then one day the power goes out and I'm
like,
what do you do when the power goes out?
Well,
what I usually do is I sit around and
wait.
I figured someone's fixing that shit.
Then that person is that person's dead
and no one would know what happened to.
Yeah.
And the,
uh,
the idea that job was if I left you
alone alone in the woods with a hatchet,
how long before you could send me an
email like,
oh,
how long would it take?
Nobody knows how to make a fucking
computer.
Nobody knows how to build an engine.
Who the fuck knows how to forge metal,
pull it,
pull it out of the ground and turn into
a cash buyer.
You know what I mean?
I couldn't.
I meAn I would literally,
if I started a fire,
it would be based on shit I saw on
survivor.
I swear to god.
I think I could start a fire if I have
the right stuff,
but you have to make sure you have the
right stuff and it wouldn't be easy.
It's not easy at all.
Like you'd have to have rope and a stick
and stick.
Yeah.
Like that sort of thing that they do.
It becomes a bow and then like it seems,
I don't know when to like
yo go over to the thing to the.
Well,
you know,
there's a guy on,
on,
um,
there's a show called life below zero
and this fucking dude doesn't bring
matches with him because he doesn't want
to rely on matches because what if I,
what if I run out of matches?
Yeah,
I would if I rely on live.
So he,
his mouthpiece thAt he puts in and then
he has a stick,
put cv,
there's a video of it.
His name is glenn.
Pull up glenn from life below zero,
makes a fire on youtube and he puts this
bit,
is this piece in his mouth and the piece
like clamps down on the top of the stick
so that he could use the bow with two
hands and really get a lot of friction.
so you as the bow that's wrapped around
those string of the bose wrapped around
the stick and he's going right to left,
right to left,
right to left.
And as,
as it spins,
the friction starts,
see little smoke and he's pushing like
dry can tinder in there.
And then he gets like a little ball of
fire and then he builds it up.
How long have you see it?
It doesn't.
No.
It doesn't make too much to carry around
in your mouth,
right?
Sure.
It has to be online.
If it's not online,
they should be fired.
Here we go.
So this guy,
this is how he does it all the time.
Give it some,
some volume.
So we'll see.
I don't use a headlamp because what
happens if I run out of headlamps?
It's true.
It's 40 below zero waste.
Filming what this mouthpiece is made out
of caribou.
This guy's supported living so gangster
up there.
So he holds his caribou antler piece in
his mouth.
Then he wraps a string around his
fucker.
Watch how he does this.
This is pretty wild.
So he's pulling right left,
right,
right.
And watch how quick it works.
Wow.
Isn't that nuts?
yeah.
It's incredible.
And he has this fire starting thing.
Any reuse it over and over again because
the more he does it,
his teeth are ruined.
We should point out yes.
Either fart bite,
not caribou antlers.
Bitch was trying to do.
And so then he reuses that the little
thin plate of wood that he has
underneath it.
Reuse that over and over again.
So it's sort of blAck and charred,
which makes it a little bit more
flammable.
None.
AmazIng.
That's awesome.
saw this motherfucker.
Makes her fire.
And you saw a quick.
It was.
Yeah.
But joe kenney write a joke.
Nope,
he's not perfect.
He's not.
He's not the uber mush.
I have him write a sketch.
Nope.
See how they look at you.
You're.
Yeah.
Well you think you could do this?
Hey,
strongest man.
Do a fucking strong seven bro.
Yeah.
How about you write for chris rock?
Strongest man.
You fucking piece of fucking jumoke.
Oh great.
You could pick up a big stone ball.
You fucking done.
You know what else can do that
attractor?
Yeah.
You're human tractor.
Fuckface yeah.
With jokes.
Yeah.
Go do,
do it.
Take seven.
The crowd up your warm.
The crowd up for at midnight.
Brody's job.
Enjoy it.
Eight one.
He yelled out.
Eight.
One eight till I die last night on
stage.
And the fucking place broke out into
applause when he was at the ice house
last night when he was hilarious.
Yeah,
he's very funny.
But the yelling out eight,
one eight till I die.
and the place just wet.
Yeah.
That's great.
They know,
they know what to expect from brody
stevens.
I like that.
He's
like carved out a little thing from some
people have like really like kimmel.
Those kinds of guys like people who
really appreciate brody have made a big
girl.
But zach alpha access to.
Yeah,
big,
big fan made a big deal about them.
It's really,
it's nice to see them getting.
He still doesn't get the attention that
it deserves.
I want to do something where we do it in
conjunction with the comedy store and we
filmed brody's late night sets.
Just film a gang of them and then find
the gem,
find that one jam and take that and turn
it into a comedy special.
Yeah.
Because someone easy to do because some
of those shelves that he Does,
those late night shows,
they're just fucking magical.
Magical shows.
Like very inspired.
Yeah.
Just not off the fucking charts weird,
you know,
the narratives that he creates in the
audience with the various people that
he's fucking around with all completely
ad lib as opposed to those fake ad lib
guys.
You know those fake ad lib guys I know
exists.
I haven't caught anyone.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
Are there some that we know?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
Not that much anymore because people are
getting hip to it,
but there used to be a bunch of guys who
every night would pretend,
look at this guy.
He's thinking,
well,
he's like,
and she's wired wrong,
but they say the same thing every night
and everyone like,
oh my god,
it's so brilliant.
Yeah.
But it's really an act.
It's an act that pretends to be an ad
libbed act.
Yeah.
I would agree with that motherfucker.
This motherfucker making,
you know,
how dare they make 61 grand a year?
How dare they feel lucky.
Yeah.
So tell me about this fucking thing that
you just did.
All right.
For anybody who doesn't know what
ketamine is,
I will tell them.
I'll tell the whole narrative.
The last one of the times I was here,
we talked about five htP.
Yeah.
Um,
that was a long time ago.
That got me into it and that's how when
we started creating new mood.
Yeah.
so I taken five htp.
I basically had depression most of my
adult life,
probably my whole life.
ANd uh,
and when you define depression,
like right now I'm talking to you.
We're hanging out,
we're having fun,
we're laughing.
Everything seems cool right now.
You're great.
Yeah.
When does it slip in it?
Here's the thing,
it's not,
I was never suicidal.
It was never,
it was just like kind of a,
like the best I could feel what I could
feel his adrenaline and ego,
do you know what I mean?
But it was never like joy,
happiness,
sort of,
you know,
like the more I'm fuzzy or stuff,
so I couldn't feel.
It just didN't happen.
No joy,
no happiness.
Not really.
Again,
not but not miserable.
Okay.
But let me ask you this,
while this is going on and great things
would happen to.
Yeah,
like you had some great things
happening.
first of all,
you know the cocreative chappelle show,
which is,
in my opinion,
the greatest sketch comedy the world's
ever known.
Yeah.
so that was a great thing.
Yes.
During that time,
was there joy?
Uh,
there was ego ego and there was
adrenaline,
but there was never.
It never felt like my brain would like
talk me out of it.
It would talk me out of why I should Be,
why I should enjoy it,
if that makes sense.
like it would talk me out of it,
just like,
well,
yeah,
but you,
you had a partner and you get to do
this.
Okay.
So your brain would tell you,
well,
you know,
you're doing well,
but let's be honest,
you're doing it beCause of dave
chappelle and,
you know,
even though you're running is really
great,
would it be so great if skippy from
family ties are the star of the show?
The show would still,
I would say yes.
Okay.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
No disrespect to skippy.
Yeah.
Um,
so that was,
that's when I knew I needed to go on
antidepressants is I sold a script in
like 1999 and I was on the phone with an
agent who was saying that to studios
were bidding for it and I was driving up
labrea crying
on the phone with the guy and tears were
running down my face.
I'm like,
this isn't right.
wow.
Yeah.
So you were crying because you still
felt like shit.
Yeah,
just
felt like shit.
Yeah.
I just felt like shit,
I am part of the shit was like,
I can't even fucking enjoy this.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like just like I wish I could
feel this shit.
Right.
So your tiers were like tiers of like,
god damn it,
how come I can't even feel this?
Like why even do this shit right if
you're not.
And that's what I would get out of his
ego,
like,
like adrenaline from being in a cool
situation or doing something cool or
whatever.
Even killing onstage.
Like for example,
people,
when I know certain people get offstage
when,
for instance chris rock to bring them up
again,
when he gets off stage,
he is the nicest.
He's so fucking gacked off of the crowd.
He so just like high on adrenaline and
like just good feeling and basically
like,
uh,
like just good,
like a fucking chemicals that are
escaping me.
But like serotonin shit like that,
he's just hits yet domain san antonio,
he's just fucking flying,
right?
I would never feel like that.
I feel like,
oh,
I just fucking murdered.
But I would never be like,
cause I'm,
there was no,
I wouldn't enjoy it,
enjoy it.
I wouldn't not enjoy it.
But it was flat.
It was flat.
It was like,
I might not,
I might as well have not done that,
but it didn't.
Me and deb one time talked about about
getting upstaged.
Sometimes you just want to take the mic
and throw it down.
[inaudible].
It's like,
well fucking,
that didn't even help.
Um,
so,
so I've taken antidepressants for,
since I was crying on the price in 1999.
So,
uh,
so I took them and I zoloft at first
were great,
really work well and I remember telling
a chappelle,
I think I said I go,
I now know why people dance.
Like that was how I knew like,
oh,
this works because I understand the
feeling that it would make people want
to dance or just like that sort of
collective.
Um,
do you want to vive for lack of better
word.
So,
so did that.
Took zoloft probably worked for 10
years,
nine,
10 years,
you know,
with very in fact,
but after awhile it just stopped
working.
Now when it stopped working,
when I or when I would try to go off it,
my,
I would get like a tension in my.
I'm a fucking temple that literally
couldn't like a knot in my template.
Like if you needed to get massaged it
would just form.
And that's how I knew like oh,
I'm fucking depressed again because it
would just form.
Um,
and what,
what was,
when you said it wasn't working.
So what was the shift?
It starteD working in beginning.
It was great.
Yeah,
there is a term for it and I always
forget it,
but it's like that.
It just stopped.
It's like an efficacy,
longterm efficacy.
Just
tampers decreases.
Yeah.
And that's specific to zoloft.
It's all them,
all of them.
It can be all of them.
Um,
so then I switched to a I've,
and then probably the last four or five
years I've switched a bunch because all
the ones I tried had some side effect.
What is the feeling though that you have
on them?
Is it like a feeling of you have like
more energy?
Do you have a little more enthusiasm?
You have more.
You have like more generosity of spirit,
if that makes sense.
Like,
just like you want your less of like a
hater.
Hmm.
Uh,
because you're not,
you don't feel so depleted yourself that
you can actually be like,
oh,
that's good man.
That's fucking awesome.
What's hard for people to be happy for
other people?
If they're not happy about 100 percent,
it's very hard because no one's mean
because they're in a good mood.
You know what I mean?
Like other people don't deserve
happiness.
You can't get it.
Yeah.
Why the fuck did you get it?
Um,
so that's like any troll.
It's like you just see it's because
you're unhappy man.
It's like I get it.
Just don't take my success isn't your
failure,
but that's how it feels because you
can't do it.
You can't even get.
Not can.
Not only can you not do standard,
whatever the thing they're mad at you
for,
they can't even feel what they imagine
you feel from doing it.
Uh,
so,
so I tried a bunch.
The last four or five years they would
work with are some side effects.
Nausea,
a one.
I was like gaining weight and I wasn't
eating and I was gaining weight.
Um,
Yeah,
it was so weird.
I'm a shit like that.
And then the last one was um,
nausea and my dick was in a coma.
well,
like literally I took a fucking pro,
the boner drug and um,
agora.
Yeah,
it didn't work.
But yeah,
generally how fucking like
dan,
it was like literally,
it's like put the bucket and chart what
the fucking clear.
Clear back nothing.
Wow.
Yeah.
So you had to get off that immediately.
Well the.
Yeah.
It was so important.
Happiness or boners?
Well,
what was interesting is it was,
it was,
it was interesting for the few months
that I had it to not have to worry aBout
boners boners are pursuing,
girls are fucking texting and,
and,
and tendering and all that shit.
Just like I don't give a shit.
Wow.
Now when they seem like nice people,
now what does it do?
Does it,
does it somehow another deplete your
testosterone?
Does it?
I don't know why that.
The thing about antidepressants,
they don't know why they work.
They know that they work.
They have theories about why they work.
Like the.
I was on a class of antidepressants
called ssrs,
which are short for a selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitor,
which means it's basically a double
negative,
a re uptake inhibitor.
It's basically when you,
when the,
when the serotonin goes out,
usually it gets collected quickly,
but if you take this drug,
it leaves the serotonin out in your
brain longer.
I believe sarah re uptake inhibitor.
Yeah.
So it gets,
it inhibits the uptake so it like,
hey,
stay out.
Hey,
run around a little bit,
you know what I mean?
Saratoga.
So if you take,
if you take the drug,
I think if I,
if I didn't take the drug it would be a,
I don't know,
I guess it was my brain would collect it
super quick.
I'm of the mind that I don't have enough
serotonin to begin with.
Like I just have,
I feel like I have a serotonin
deficiency naturally,
but whatever.
So uh,
so I'm.
So my dick was in a coma and I was
throwing up like pretty regularly.
Like how often?
Like three Days a week.
Wow.
I just be driving and go like,
oh,
I'm going to throw up and throw up and
then be fine.
So essentially what these drugs you're
trying to somehow or another reengineer
your,
your neuro chemical makeup?
Yeah.
I mean you're trying to help it
basically.
I don't think you can reengineer it.
I'll get to the reengineering,
but I don't.
I think with the drugs you just go like,
it's basically a bandaid.
It just like,
hey,
reroute ain't go over there.
It's never like you're,
you're fucking synapses are in different
places.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
but it's amazing that they're doing this
and they're not exactly sure as you say,
how they work.
Yeah.
They don't.
They really don't.
They have theory.
Obviously they know that ssrs radio,
they selectively,
you know,
up to the whatever fucking.
But they don't know exactly.
They don't even know if,
if it'S in your brain or if it's in your
stomach,
there's a new thing.
There was an article in the atlantic two
days ago that's saying a lot of.
First of all,
you're all of like all those chemicals
we talked about,
lIke sarah tunnel and stuff.
It's mostly in your stomach.
Um,
which people don't know.
so they are basically saying like,
they're,
they're lookIng in people's feces and
they think that the amount of chemicals
or combinations you have in your
stomach,
it can affect mood.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well,
that's what the concept behind
probiotics affecting the mood are 100
percent.
By the way.
I was getting a bunch of colds and I
started taking probiotics and haven't
got one to die harm.
I almost never get sick.
Yeah.
I drink kombucha everyday.
I have a,
the gts kombucha,
the kind that you have to have an id to
show because it is moRe than one half of
one percent of our.
That's all it is.
A tiny,
tiny.
You'd have to drInk like 30 of them to
catch the bus you'd get from one beer,
but it's worth it.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
it's,
it's a stupid law,
but the probiotic effect of the
fermentation of this live cultures,
it's causing the alcohol.
yeah.
But it's so good for you,
man.
YeAh,
it's been crazy.
Changed my life.
Like traveling.
you should make me sick.
It was always getting sick.
I don't get sick anymore.
If I do get sick,
it's very quick in and out.
So quick turnaround.
Yeah.
I would highly recommend it because if
you're traveling all the time on a,
as a comIc on the road,
like your immune system takes a fucking.
Even in firstclass gel,
it does.
Even first class I wrote coach the other
day for the first time in a long time,
people were touching me,
sitting there,
I was like,
why are you touchIng your leg is
touching my leg.
Whatever you get.
It's obviously something comforting
about that.
Everybody's touching each other.
He's sitting there and you're,
you know that your arm's gonna touch the
guy next to you and everybody accepts
that we're all.
This is the world we're living in.
Okay.
I mean,
why is that bad?
As long as everyone's arm is touching
everyone.
Yeah,
I'm cool.
And as long as no one gets greedy with
the,
as long as everyone's like,
friendly with the space,
you know,
you don't man spread and bop into the
other guy's side and you know,
but also hygiene,
that's a big one.
It's huge because if you touch them
people and they stink,
that's fucking brutal.
And I've had that.
How long the flight was two flights.
What happened was I'm to vegas or
something.
No,
it was to Canada.
I fucked up and I'm so stupid.
just donor move.
My flight takes off.
It took off at a certain time.
And uh,
I had it written the time I was supposed
to get up,
uh,
had reversed.
So instead of thinking that I was
supposed to get up at 9:00
flight,
the flight was at 9:00
and I was like,
oh no.
Like I thought the flight was at like 11
and I got there in the future.
I think
you should just go based on what time of
flight leaves.
I don't leave it up to the airline,
what time you should wake up,
what was just such a boneheaded move.
I just had too many different things
going on and I wrote it down somewhere
and you just incorrectly wrote it down.
Yeah.
But anyway,
point being I had to switch the flights,
blah blah blah.
And I was thinking like,
it's kinda like the only time where
people ever touched people that they
don't know except jujitsu class maybe,
you know.
And then you try to kill each other.
Mass transit,
mass transit.
Especially like you said,
tokyo,
rather that they push people in.
They literally have guys whose jobs are
to shove people deeper and deeper into
those boxes.
Yeah,
they're made,
they make six figures doing that.
People get depressed,
some people get depressed from a lack of
human contact.
Absolutely.
I'll get to that in a second.
UM,
so.
Okay.
So I was just like taking like the last
one.
I was like,
I'm so sick of fucking taking
[inaudible] the thing with
antidepressant pills is that you don't,
It's a complete guessing it what's gonna
work for you?
Because the one I was taking that was
making my dick fall asleep and make me
throw up was supposed to have the lowest
uh,
side effect profile of all of them.
But I've had ones that had more that
were supposed to do worship shit and
they didn't.
So,
so I was like,
I'm so sick of this,
so I just started looking up other shit
to do.
Um,
and the,
the big one that I,
that kept coming up that I saw was
ketamine.
So I was like,
that's interesting.
Like I didn't really,
I knew it was like a party drug and I
didn't really know that much about it.
It's a very weird party drugs.
Yeah.
I haven't done it.
I'm like,
why the fuck would you ever take that
around people?
Um,
but,
so,
so there's a guy in santa monica,
dr stephen,
man dell,
and um,
that's a picture of me getting to talk
about this guy on.
I don't know.
I mean,
I think I can.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
I mean,
the guy's name he mentioned,
I don't mind if you.
Okay.
So,
uh,
so he,
he,
he was an anesthesiologist who basically
came up with a Regimen for,
that's for depression and he's,
by the way,
he's not the only one.
Like there's,
there's probably hundreds in America
right now that are doIng this with
ketamine.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Uh,
especially if you go on reddit or um,
and he liked the ending of the boards
and any kind of like a antidepressant
boards or whatever.
Uh,
there's people that did it and there's
another one called tms,
which is the other one that's making a
comeback is just the,
the cuckoo's nest one,
the electrical shock therapy because
they were doing it wrong apparently.
And there a way to do it now,
like you just,
the,
the amperage was too high.
So there was just fucking fry cooking if
you cook it a little bit.
Yeah,
exactly.
You don't want to it.
Yeah.
Precisely.
You little something steam it.
Yeah.
You can punch in a.
but you should throw an egg on you,
your fucking website.
So that's,
that's made a comeback.
And then there's another one called
transcranial magnetic stimulation where
they just basically shoot magnet,
said your brain.
Um,
and,
but that's five days a week for five
weeks.
academy kids.
The treatment is you do six sessions in
two weeks.
Oh,
I'm.
So it's monday,
wednesday,
friday of two weeks.
And I did it last week and the week
before.
So first time I go in a and again,
I don't know if I could have researched
it all.
I knew that was what then you,
when you go in you have basically when
you do ketamine you have like an out of
body sort of experienced meaning,
like a dissociative experience.
So which seems pretty vague.
Um,
so I,
so he hooks the ivy up and um,
and within 15 seconds I was like gone.
Like at first you just get sleepy and
then I was in the trip that you were
talking about things to fucking
geometric shapes,
all kinds.
The thing about tripping that I forgot
is how good the transitions are,
is like it'll go from geometric safety,
like a bear's face to just like just
crazy shit for 45 minutes.
Um,
and then you come out of it and you
slowly come out of it and you were like
noise canceling headphones.
I'm just at a doctor's office,
like in a weird,
not even weird,
like those like 19 seventies doctors'
offices that you see in la,
like just sort of a shitty elevator and
whatever.
Um,
so when I came out of the first one I
was like,
it was rough because I didn't know it
was going to trip like that.
And b,
I had been,
I didn't get a ton of sleep the night
before and uh,
so I was,
and I'd flown that day.
I was just kind of groggy and uh,
and I felt really shitty and it took me
like I was like,
after I was done,
I probably laid in the bed there for
like an hour,
so it was like,
I can't do shit right now.
Like I can't,
I could barely stand.
So the first day was rough and uh,
and that I still felt shitty that night
and I was like,
I don't think I'm going to do it again.
Like,
that was too rough.
And then I woke up tuesday morning and
felt fucking great.
I was like,
oh,
um,
I got to do it again,
felt great.
I felt clear.
Here's the,
one of the ways my,
uh,
depression manifested itself was like,
I felt my head felt heavy and I felt
like I had like,
I had like a lead weight on my forehead,
you know,
that's the way I felt when I did
ecstasy.
You say after the day after I felt it
felt amazing when I did it.
And that's what it is because it
depletes.
Yeah.
You get all the serotonin's gun.
And that's basically what people with
depression a lot of times are like just
everyday isn't just like a headwind.
It's not,
it's just like fucking,
could thIs be a little bit easier,
like I'm not asking for a miracle and
just like I'm just sick of having to
walk into the wind all the time.
Right.
A little bit uphill into the windows.
Fuck.
Alright.
So I did it again that wednesday and
every time I did it,
um,
the,
the other thing that,
one of the ways that they kind of gauge
it as,
do you do like a inventory,
a questionnaire,
like a 25 question questionnaire.
Like how do you feel about your future?
And like,
it's like not good,
fine,
neutral,
whatever.
Um,
each one has a point value.
They add it up if it's like in the teens
or high teens or twenties,
that means you're depressed if you're in
the under,
you know,
the low teens,
you're good,
whatever.
And I think mine went from low twenties
to like single digits in the two weeks.
Wow.
And the only downside,
and I can't get it like perfectly clear
read because I'm quitting the ssri when
the,
the one that,
the deq killer,
I'm quitting that at the same time.
so I'm just like,
that's,
I'm sort of having withdrawal from that
and the way it was manifesting itself
for a couple of weeks was like,
I just felt like shit.
I just felt like I had the flu but not
coughing or sneezing.
Just like rundown.
When you wean yourself off of an ssri,
is there a protocol for doing that?
This paper,
that's all you can do.
And whEn they say taper,
like you have like x,
do you get smaller pills?
Dei.
You just clip them in half and that's
what I did.
And you take less of them?
Yeah.
You just do you go?
I was on 21 to 10.
One to five nomad.
Zero.
And in how long you've been at zero?
I don't know.
I think three or four weeks.
So how do you feel?
Right now?
I feel I feel better every day from the,
from the ssri effect has gotten better
every day.
I feel like I don't feel nauseous,
I'm not nauseous,
just like,
I don't feel like shit.
The onlY way it's kind of manifesting
itself now is like,
one of my eyes is a little flight.
Feels like I have something in it.
Just the gay.
I got it.
J and j guy.
Um,
what it is.
Uh,
yeah.
So one of my eyes feels a little gay,
so as he was,
there's no other word for it.
Um,
so I just put eyedrops in.
That's it.
Yeah.
And it might be unrelated.
The eyeball thing that I think it's
related because I've looked it up.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There's like,
there's,
you know,
ssri withdrawal if you just google that
and they have eyeballs issues.
Yeah.
It's like you'll be a little cloudy,
huh?
Some people,
it usually lasts like three weeks.
Some people.
I've seen guys on reddit that were like,
I fucking had this for six months.
Jesus,
which would make me crazy,
I think.
Yeah.
How could you not be?
So let me ask You this,
so you,
you take it the first time and how many
days afterwards did you feel great?
You said two,
one,
one day the next day feel like shit
after it's over.
Felt like shit the after it was over,
felt like basically went home and just
laid in my,
on my account.
Did you feel like physically worn out?
Like
I just felt like,
um,
I guess like I had a high fever,
you know,
that feeling.
It's just like I can't do shit.
Was it possible that it was the stress
of the experience?
Because you didn't know?
Possibly.
Yeah,
because you ever haD anesthesia.
You don't want to come out of it.
It feels that's like my least favorite
feeling in the world.
That's basically what it was that
feeling of like,
oh fuck.
Like I could throw up.
I'm not gonna.
So it could be a bunch of issues.
Do you have the same feeling every time
he did it?
Yeah.
Basically I would need to take a nap
every time.
Yeah.
Um,
because basically when I did it on the
wednesday,
I took a nap and did a spot that night.
Wow.
Yeah.
Um,
I ran into that night.
We talked about,
it was at the improv.
Maybe my ran into you at the store and
you told me the last treatment that day.
Yeah,
but that was friday.
It was like a less than a week ago.
Yeah,
I'm okay.
It's different time that end,
that friday because I had done it
enough,
but what I found,
what was interesting was every session
it would take me longer to go into the
trip,
meaning like my body was getting used
to.
It was building up a tolerance for it,
for the ketamine.
How long haS it's all ivy ivy based.
The first time,
like I said,
20 seconds and the last time was
probably four or five minutes.
Oh yeah.
And he was upping The dose I think.
Wow.
I'm so
well I ran into after the first time you
did it and I ran into you.
I think friday was after the last time
you did it.
Yeah.
And unfortunately we didn't have a
chance to talk much until now,
so I couldn't like get an objective
sense of how you seemed.
Yeah.
What was Interesting was like the friday
of the first week I had,
it might have been friday or saturday,
but there was a thing that was happening
to me on stage where I was for like
months.
I felt shitty.
You know,
when you feel shitty,
you can't kill that hard.
Like there's basically a cap.
I had a cap on my sets for months and it
was making me fucking crazy because it
was like eighth.
Not me,
like it's my,
it's a this fucking eighth depRession
beats the ssrs and now it's the ssrs and
the a ketamine,
but I on the friday or saturday I
fucking murdered in the main room,
which you know,
is like a but it because I was clear.
Do you know what I mean?
Like I was finallY like,
oh,
I know the audience wouldn't feel like a
slugginess to me.
There was like a real,
like,
you know,
more of just like a laser focus.
Yeah,
on point.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
I've had nights Where I'm tired.
That is the worst god damn feelIng when
you're exhausted and trying to come up
with energy to go on stage when you're
physically our bodies physically
exhausted.
Yeah.
So you were kind of battling that a lot
and so then you're taking it
affects writing to machine depressed.
Like I haven't written.
I've,
I thiNk I've got basically two an hour
but it took me like two years.
Like it wasn't like I'm not like you
where I can take a couple months and
just come with the newer bernie.
These guys like first of all,
I think it would take me longer than six
months anyway,
but it was in part of it.
I wanted to go like I'm,
my fucking brain isn't working because I
just run out of options in terms of ssri
and shit.
So I'm also,
that's a primary focus of your mind.
It's like how do,
how the fuck do I get happy?
You're trying to million different
medications,
all these different ideas and like it's
just frustrating.
So.
Okay.
So you do it the first time and then the
next day you feel great.
You are still on the ssri or your
window?
I was done.
I mean i'vE done now withdrawing off of
them because this is something that is a
big issue with iowasca.
No,
the I say,
look,
I'm talking to john bosco.
Oh,
you take iowasca guilt die,
right?
Well,
it's very dangerous.
Ssri or dangerous with iowasca with
dimethyltryptamine,
with in mushrooms are very closely
related to d to dimethyltryptamine.
Yeah.
There's people that take mushrooms and
they also are taking an ssri and I've
heard that.
That's kind of funky too.
I'm trying to think if I've ever done
that.
Ari was on ssri I think,
and he was taking mushrooms,
so I think I've done that.
Maybe he was on a different kind of.
I think I've met a pagan ssri.
I know for a fact are.
He did ask his doctor and told him and
apparently the type of medication he was
on,
it was fine with nordstrom's.
The ta,
I think I did it once or twice on ssr is
fine,
which really dangerous apparently is if
you take a prescription mao inhibitor
and then you take mushrooms or you take
iowasca,
then it's super fucking devic.
Mio.
Mao inhibitors have a big profile which
like don't take it to the other shit
that has more.
That's on more warning for the most
thing.
Yeah,
I,
I believe I've read this.
I'm like 98 percent sure I read this.
Most people.
Oh,
I did read it.
It was a,
this guy Carl Hart,
who'd be a great guest.
Adam.
Oh,
alright,
there you go.
That guy's fucking awesome.
I'm said that most people that die of
heroin overdoses are drunk like the,
the most of the overdoses are because
they combined it with alcohol.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
He was on o'reilly the other day and I
texted him.
I was like,
how the fuck do you do that?
Like you talked for five seconds and
he's touching you,
and then they caught away him for a
breaking news report on the lady getting
arraigned and upstate New York for
helping the prisoners escape.
There's a panel,
there's him and a bunch of other people.
They're all talking about drugs and he
barely got a chance to talk.
It's also like,
what good does that shit too.
That's what I always wonder.
Like when they go,
hey,
you want to come on a panel on cnn?
I'm like,
no,
I'm not going to change any minds.
And it's also shitty way of community.
Yeah,
exactly.
This is the way to communicate.
Yes.
This is the best way in woodland hills.
Hit it off as part.
Yeah.
That's shitty.
Office park.
This is the way to do it,
right?
Under lighting.
So you.
So you go and you do it the first time
that day afterwards,
you start to feel better in the way.
Uh,
I would compare the trip in and of
itself the actual trip like lsd,
lsd,
but ellis without the speed.
But with a lot of visuals though.
All visuals.
All visual.
Yeah.
Crazy.
the way mckenna described ketamine,
I've never done ketamine the way,
um,
you know,
makenna and john lilly was a huge
pioneer of ketamine,
you know,
gun.
John lilly's the guy who invented the
isolation tank,
one of his things that he used to like
to do is shoot ketamine in a muscularly,
intramuscularly,
shove it right into his fucking muscle.
I think that's what I did.
I mean you did it,
but the intramuscular is a slower
release and apparent last for hours and
he would bang whack himself and climate
of the tank and be gone for a fun day.
Just zoom around crazy and mckenna
described it like he.
This is a very interesting way of
describing psychedelics.
He believed whether or not I was to
correct it,
but he believed that every psychedelic
you take your.
You're experiencing not just your trip,
but the trip of all the people who've
ever tripped on that psychedelic.
So when you're taking mushrooms,
you're not just experiencing the
mushroom,
you're experiencing the mushroom as it
has interfaced with countless human
beings,
all throughout humanity,
all the different people have taken the
mushrooms and had these beautiful
experiences.
You experienced those experiences as
well.
It's.
Yeah,
but I,
I don't,
I don't disagree.
I don't agree with that because I can't
put it seems like.
Yeah,
that's possible,
but what he said about ketamine was he
felt like ketamine was a new drug and
these felt like when he took ketamine
that he was in a giant office building
that was empty.
It's like a vacant office building.
He's like,
he would walk around and there was no
one there who would like look around.
There was cubicles,
there was lights,
there was this big open spaces,
but there was no one in the room.
it was just devoid of the kind of
experience that you have when you take
other sorts of psychedelics.
Did you expire within
the things that.
I remember one of the things I remember
was like getting.
I would start on me and then just pull
out wide,
like a,
for lack of a better example,
like google maps or in my head it was
more like,
um,
grand theft auto and like where I am,
uh,
there's the,
the,
I'm in santa monica and I just go,
there's California,
there's whatever.
like,
um,
I was aware of every sort of your whole
experience of people that I went to high
school with people that I know now,
like just every woman's sort of,
they're not like actually,
but sort of,
you know,
I think about them.
Um,
and then it was like I was in the matrix
is too simplistic.
But you,
did you see the new,
uh,
lAnded the last perhaps will pharrel
there's just a weird black void scene.
Like it's like basically a black void
with like a tron floor.
Um,
this was like a,
it was,
there was no tron floor,
like the,
the,
it was a white sort of,
it was more of a disco floor actually
then have white.
This was,
I didn't have the disco floor but I did
have the sort of black void and then
shit would form out of that and it was
sort of lit the,
like it was like the fill lighting as
they call it would be green.
so like the way your walls red it would
be great.
Um,
so,
and it was a very,
he just made a great.
I'm back there.
So the trip was pleasant,
it was never like,
I've never freaked out.
I never.
Did you experience at entities,
does anything that you were
communicating with you,
there was all just shapes?
Yeah,
it was all shapes.
So it was just shapes and feelings,
like shapes and like I would think of
stuff.
And when you say you would think of
stuff,
was the stuff that you would think of
related to depression?
Was it related to that?
Because what I'm trying to do right,
you know what I mean?
Um,
so like what kind of stuff was going
through your head while you're having
this?
Like about it,
like love and fucking like the time I
went in the hulk music on,
into anytime someone starts the time I
did the,
the float labs thing made me get a dog
because I went to float labs and I
floated and I was in the middle of like,
I got you got to love something man.
And I got it up.
Um,
the uh,
and that dog has been the bane of my
existence.
I'm getting that dog has bit more people
talk to you for sending me the pills.
Old ladies.
So,
uh,
so.
So yeah,
I thought about life,
just think about it,
but it wasn't that much.
It wasn't,
it was more.
Yeah.
I thought about like,
what if there's an earthquake also like
fucking if you're,
if you're tripping on,
on like ketamine,
you're gone.
I'm,
my eyes are closed.
I couldn't open them.
Like I wouldn't physically been able to
open them.
I'm obviously what if there's an
earthquake,
but then I just feel like,
wow,
what a weird thing to focus on.
So you try to sell it to my.
It would just come into my like,
don't you get that when you're on weed
though?
sometimes I don't do weed.
Oh that's right.
We will let you consider all the
possible fuckups that could go wrong.
even the earthquake,
I was like,
man,
I get demolished till you die.
Everybody's going to die.
It felt like more of like a.
It was like,
it was going to be like the san andreas
and the rock would not say,
well,
what would they think about that?
When it comes to psychedelic experiences
is like,
it's your thing about psychedelic
experiences that's universal is the
eagle dissolving properties of it and
they think that a lot of this wood,
that feeling is when you're trying to,
you know,
to try to think about all the things
that go wrong,
it's almost your ego not wanting to let
go.
So like,
hey,
you need the man because one of the
flood and earthquake happens,
or what if you know,
what if something's happening right now?
What if someone's breaking into your
car?
What about the paranoia and the fear?
The survival instinct as a part of the
ego.
It felt like
I was backstage in my brain.
That makes sense,
huh?
Like I was seeing the mechanations I was
feeling,
but I'd also like see the see like how
it got there.
So you can see the wiring.
Yeah,
that's what I always feel like when I
do.
When I did lsd,
am I.
When I,
when I did the ketamine,
I was like,
oh,
it feels like you're.
It feels like my brain.
I feel like I'm like getting a tour of
my brain.
So what supposed to be the mechanism for
repair or for and another thing that
they don't know
really know they don't know,
but I can tell you that it worked like
[inaudible].
I felt I felt better every day.
It has to do with the ssrs for sure.
But I Also feel like the thing that's
been,
I've been noticing is,
and thIs is such a weird symptom of
improvement,
I've been laughing at my own jokes more,
which sounds like it's fucking.
Oh,
so you're an egomaniac.
No,
I'm just enjoying the idea as like an
independent thing,
right?
Like I'm having fun like me and this
person are playing for lack of a better
word.
LIke we're just fucking around,
like,
like.
So that to me is a symptom of feeling
better and I also physical
please feel better.
Wow.
Okay.
So the first one makes you feel better.
Is there an increase every time you do
it?
Two through six.
He didn't tell me.
I,
I'm betting there was.
You mean an increase in dosage?
I'm at an eight.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Because I feel it would take me longer
to get into the trip and then the
hangover would be way less.
Like I think last friday I didn't take a
nap.
Wow.
Uh,
in fact I know it didn't take a nap
cause I got it at four and I had like an
eight,
15.
So I did.
I was tripping from 4:15
to five and then figured out how to go
and had a good set.
Wow.
yeah.
So is this something that you're going
to have to repeat or is it supposed to
be like you whack it out and point?
Uh,
the,
how long it lasts is,
is you know,
various.
Um,
he said it could be few weeks,
can be a few months.
He did tell me,
he said this will,
these are the things that will make it
last longer.
Diet,
exercise,
obvious sleep.
He said to sleep with the sun.
It's like let wake up early if you can.
Like.
And another doctor told me that like,
more serotonin is produced early in the
day than,
uh,
than late.
So after the job is probabLy to wake
early to rise.
Yeah,
that's basically like,
that's better for your mental health.
Keeps him helped.
Um,
so.
So yeah,
if like going to bed,
what are you trying to wake up at?
Seven or eight.
But how are you going to go to bed
early?
You're a comic.
I haven't yet.
That's not going to work,
right?
Just going to be tired all the time.
no,
but I can go to bed.
They're weeks,
days during the week I go to bed at
midnight or one.
I do feel like there's ideas that are
available to you when you wake up early
in the morning that aren't available to
you at any other time of the day.
Like yeah,
sometimes I forced myself to get up
early in the morning just to sit down
and write because I think sometimes I
forced myself awake.
Like I'll set my alarm for six and then
I'll get up and I'll sit in front of the
computer at 6:30
AM all cloudy I'd but then somewhere on
like six,
26,
45,
six slash 15 slash 20 minutes later I
start getting ideas.
Yeah.
And then they start coming out and then
there's like,
this is initial wake up and then the
coffee hits in and is initial wakeup
ideas I think are almost different
because they're really connected to the
sleep world.
You were just sleeping just a small
amount of time ago and you can't.
You don't have defenses at that point.
You can't be like stupid.
You're just like,
oh yeah,
well that's one of the reasons why
people like write like writing really
silly shit late at night.
Like the news radio writers,
they didn't even start working until
like 2:00
in the morning.
I think that was mostly paul.
Yeah,
paul,
it was.
Paul had been in his twenties and it was
also a method to his madness.
Like paul knew what he was doing and
they would write the silliest shit cause
they were barely awake.
They were just like laughing.
And I'd always heard that that show,
they just play video games.
That's mostly what the writers,
they got me addicted.
They had a local area network set up
with computers playing quake on them and
you would go there and we'd all played
real time against each other and talk
shit,
laugh and oh my god,
it was so addictive.
I liked being up.
That's the thing.
It's not like I don't like getting up,
but I like being a right,
getting up as the hard part.
forcing yourself to get up out of bed.
You know what?
I have a thing on my phone that's really
funny and like it's either for you or
not.
It's called.
It's an app called.
I can't wake up.
Right,
okay.
It's an alarm clock.
It goes off it like plays,
music or whatever,
chime or vibrates,
whatever.
In order to turn it off,
you have to basically enter a code,
so it's like a 25 or 30 character code
caps numbers.
Lower case takes fucking 55 seconds
and by the time you're done you're like,
fucking,
I'm up.
Oh my god.
If you're doing that next to a girl,
if you're dating a girl and she doesn't
have to get up,
she'd be so mad at you fucking asshole.
He just out of the battery.
Yeah,
that's,
it's really funny.
And it works.
Actually.
I have no problem getting up.
I don't like it,
but I do it.
Yeah.
But I've,
I grew up getting up every day because I
had a paper route for the time.
I Was like 17 till I was like 21,
maybe even 22.
Kept it until um,
so I guess I'm used to just get up,
get up,
get the other.
So diet,
exercise,
get them with the sun.
and um,
it was interesting.
Was at the fair talk therapy.
Fun.
Do you have a thing with therapy?
I got so sick of talking.
I was like,
I need a physical cure.
Like I know what the problems are.
I,
it's not making me feel better.
Like I,
it's a,
it's a fucking physical issue.
I can,
I promise you because that's pretty much
been established,
right?
I mean it's pretty much established that
are large majority of people or a large
number of people that have depression.
There iS a dip.
There's a depleted amount of serotonin.
yeah.
Well,
yes,
that's established.
Yes.
As far as I'm concerned,
it's established,
but they don't really know.
And there are certain therapies,
cbt,
cognitive behavioral therapy that works
really well for people now.
What do you do when you do that?
I don't know because I haven't done it
now.
When you're,
when you're getting,
do you get measured?
Like,
do they measure your serotonin?
They take your blood and they have.
They don't have,
they don't have a measurement for it.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Um,
look it up.
But I don't,
I've googled it because I've been like,
how the fuck do I prove this?
But theY can't have serotonin syndrome.
Right?
Where you were taking five htp and an
ssri and it gives you too much
serotonin.
It cAn really fuck with you.
Yeah.
So how do they know it's given you too
much there?
I think by the symptoms,
um,
seems like,
it seems weird that they don't have a
way of measuring what your levels are
because can they originally level the
dope?
I mean,
I don't think so.
The brain is so fucking calm.
Oh,
they know nothing.
They know nothing about it because it's
impossible to.
There's no.
you know what I mean?
It's like you can look at a heart.
Most of it that's physical,
it's just like blood,
the thing,
the liquid goes in,
then it comes out.
It's mechanical,
whereas the brain is not mechanical
will.
one of the things that you brought up
was Carl Hart,
Dr.
Carl Hart,
and there's a lot of really brilliant
people today that are trying to get
people to understand addictions and
what,
what are the root cause of addiction.
And gabor montay had uh,
some interesting stuff to say about that
too in the movie the culture high and
one of the main issues are talking about
is that a lot of these people that are
addicted that deal with addictions or
people that are depressed and people
that have like these moments in their
life,
they're trying to get over the hump
there dealing with childhood abuse or
their ge dealing with childhood stress
or really trying to tell me I have ptsd.
Yeah.
A lot of therapists will minute will you
had,
you didn't have the easiest childhood?
No,
I think it's partially like my dad never
hit me,
but he used to beat the shit out of my
brothers and I was like three,
so I think that must have been like,
yeah,
traumatic.
How could it not be?
How could it not be,
you know,
I mean I can imagine that.
I can't even imagine that.
yeah,
it was shitty.
It's just a shitty way to.
And then like there's so many kids,
you don't get enough nutrients
basically.
Yeah.
So.
And they say like a lot of that,
a lot of serotonin levels are based on
a.
That early shit
can only.
It only makes sense.
Yeah.
It only makes sense that your brain is
programmed based on the experiences that
it has to deal with.
Yeah.
And then if you're dealing with,
that's one of the things they sAy about
extremely violent neighborhoods.
Kids that grow up in violent.
Like michael irvin was telling me this,
the kids that grow up in violent
families and around violence,
tHey'd literally from the womb,
the mother as she's dealing with high
cortisol levels and stress levels and
adrenaline.
Yes.
The mother is programming the child
from,
from the time it's inside of our body to
be more reactive,
to explode till I feel like cortisol at
an early age.
I feel like killed serotonin.
You know what I mean?
I could be making that up,
but it sounds right.
So d,
would you categorize what you're doing
by having these experiences with
ketamine?
like a rewiring do you think you read?
So that's what you're saying earlier.
Think I'm cRazy,
but there have been times in the last
week,
um,
where I can feel my brain physically not
moving,
but like adjusting,
dealing
like maybe looks like certain amount of
energy was inside that area,
right?
He fucking knows what it is.
Like theY know about like dendrites and
fucking and nerve endings,
all that shit.
But they don't know About.
They don't really know.
They just know chemicals and the,
and the synopsis that's.
But they don't know exactly how they
interact.
Even.
so I felt my brain is felt different.
Physical and my sleep has been all over
the place.
One night I couldn't.
I woke up at six and couldn't get back
to sleep like,
and then another day I slept till like
11 in the morning,
you know what I mean?
Or 11 and 12 like late.
So it's been all over the place.
which let you know,
like there's an adjustment going on.
Do you get sun in your bedroom?
Yeah.
You don't sleep with curtains now
closed.
So when the sun comes in and you wake
up.
No,
that's.
Do it right now.
We're supposed to do.
That's.
That goes to that waking up sunshine.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
and the other thing,
the other symptom that I feel like it's
about as I've been writing more like
fucking thank god.
Yeah.
Thank you for not just writing more but
being more productive with your writing.
Yeah.
Right.
More productive with it.
And you don't strike me as a guy who
would be lazy,
like not
no,
but,
but like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not like,
if I don't have an idea,
I just don't.
Right,
right.
I'm not one of these people like,
nah,
there's something funny about the sky,
like let's figure it out.
That's kind of how it's been for me.
I draw,
I write entries,
right?
Like blog entries or essaYs and then I
extract funny ideas from what I've been
doing that I feel like if I sit down and
just try to write joke,
joke jokes,
it's not my style.
It's not the most effective way.
Like I create a lot of like a pulp.
There's a lot of nonsense.
Don't fucking tell me about it,
but I have accepted that as a part of
the process that like mining.
Yeah.
LIke you don't just tap into a mountain
and go,
oh look,
it's all gold,
no gold mixed in with rock and bullshit
and you got to find it.
And again,
I think some people are just better at
distilling their shit or they are shit
comes to the more distilled.
But don't you think though that for me
at least,
almost all of it sucks until I bring it
to the stage.
Like almost I have to find out what it
really is.
I have to like push it out in front of
people.
I got this new bit that I worked out
last night for the first time ever died,
ice house and as I was working in I was
like,
oh,
finally.
I know because I didn't know like
before.
I was like,
is there something in this?
I don't know if there's anything in
this.
That's the thing about comedy is you're
never sure.
Yeah.
You never fucking sure.
So I don't.
I literally go on with this guy.
I don't know.
I,
I see.
If you ask me to bet I'd lose money a
lot and then sometimes it's like a
tagline as the funniest guy in the huge
laugh and you're lIke,
oh all right.
Or a throwaway.
I'll set it.
Taking the credit.
I'll take the current figure was where I
thought.
Do you think that that attitude that,
that thinking about the credit,
like what we're talking about before
that was the boost that you got was you
would get ego and you would get
adrenaline.
You wouldn't get the joy.
Do you think that it's detrimental to
concentrate on the credit?
Do you think that it's better to achieve
like a state?
Yeah.
well that's the thing of like,
like
the thing I've said on here before,
when me and david did the show,
we wouldn't tell people who wrote what
cause it was like,
it's none of your business because
you're just going to use it to judge.
The person didn't write it,
who didn't come up with it.
So.
So yeah,
I don't,
I,
for whenever I'm with a group of people,
if I'm writing in a room,
my feeling is generally how it works
with me is I don't pitch anything for
awhile upfront and I'm like,
dude,
you fucking pissed.
I'm pissed.
I'm.
And then by the end I've either caught
up or beat most of the people,
like because I,
I just want to contribute,
you know what I meAn?
Like just I just want to contribute to
the right.
So,
but the idea,
I don't get to,
I want to,
I want to hold my own,
but I'm not like I'm going to fucking
vanquish these motherfuckers because
it's comedy.
It's like it's silly and like how you
come up
with it as come so communal that it's,
well in that sense,
but I'm talking about in the sense of
actually writing things for you,
for you on stage.
Not in the writer's room.
We write for a sitcom or something like
that.
We're talking about like you coming up
with the tagline out of nowhere and go,
well,
I'll take it.
I still want credit for that.
No,
I'm kidding.
I'm joking about it in that.
I guess it's like the ego.
It's just like,
I didn't know that was thing.
It's like the guy who invents,
that happens a lot with pharmaceuticals
actually.
They think it's for high blood pressure
and then it ends up being for,
for.
Yeah.
So it's like,
oh cool.
But I Don't whether the credit thing I
don't get too hung up with.
I'm like glad that I came up with it,
but I'm like,
you were.
There's such,
you know,
chaff,
like just fucking nothing.
Yeah.
And then it's what's nice is when you
have a thought or like a long held idea
about something and then eight years
later you come with a joke for it.
Yeah.
And for me also,
sometimes I find puzzle pieces and they,
they're like little islands and also
connect,
click together and they have a bridge
and then they become awesome.
Like I know where I'm like,
oh my god,
you puzzle buddy.
Come on now you're exciting.
Now you're a part of a little little.
Yeah.
Continent.
YeS.
Not an island anymore.
Yeah.
Because after a while,
if you have enough bits in your act,
if you have like five or six ideas or
eight or whatever,
then you can just.
You'll just end up filling up those
eight more than like,
I got to come with two more.
Just like the eight.
Get longer.
With this little puzzle pieces.
Now,
after doing these six treatments,
do you anticipate this being like a
quarterly thing that you do to just keep
your,
your brain charts in the state told me
that there's a guy who does it once a
month,
whether he feels like it needs it or
not.
Um,
by the way,
I should say it's 600 bucks a treatment.
Jesus.
Yeah.
So a lot of money.
So you are.
But by the way,
they were like,
it's 3,500
bucks.
I was like,
I'll give you name your price if it's
going to work,
I'll give you half my life saving.
I don't give a fuck.
right.
Like,
it's none of this shit means anything if
I'm not happy.
Not only that,
as an artist,
as someone who is more productive,
if you're happy.
Yeah.
It's worth a shitload of money.
That's 100 percent true.
And also more productive when your
brain's working properly.
How long has this gentleman been doing
this?
Um,
didn't ask,
but he has one guy,
anesthesiologists,
uh,
he that by trade,
he was an anesthesiologist.
And uh,
and,
and by the way,
it's also,
it's approved by the fda.
That's what's so crazy.
The first thing I said when I came out
of the trip,
I go,
I can't believe the fda approved that.
How did they know?
like,
I,
cause it works.
It's like he said,
it's like 70 to 80 percent of people
that works with the depression with,
with persistent depression,
like persistent,
kind of mildly untreatable depression.
What if people aren't depressed?
What about a guy like me?
I don't know.
Hm.
I dunno know,
continue the monkey in which you fucking
neurology there.
Yogan.
I mean they might,
I don't think it'll fucks me up.
I don't think it will fuck you up
anymore than dmt or flipped me over
there.
I was scared or anything I was going to
do iowasca.
Um,
and then the more I read about it,
I was like,
eh.
It's like,
what's my really throwing up for hours
and fighting diarrhea.
And then it alSo seemed like nebulous in
terms of a,
his,
that what happens or not.
I've only done dmt.
I've done the pure extract,
which is what would iowasca is a slow
release version of dmt.
Okay.
So what happens is with dmt,
they,
they get it down to this freebase form.
Just essentially they,
they process it down to the rock
crystals and you smoke that and you get
pure dmt or the way rick strassman did
it.
Rick strassman finally we rescheduled.
His health is doing much better and
he'll be here on august thing.
He's going to be here in august.
Um,
uh,
but he wrote a great book called dmt,
the spirit molecule.
It's basically,
I made a documentary,
right?
Yeah.
And I hosted the documentary.
It's in my queue.
Joe.
Yeah,
we'll go watch a beautiful.
Um,
and.
But the,
it was,
it means you're connected to rick's
work,
but it was a lot of other experts and
dennis mckenna on a lot of different
people interviewed talking about the
drug.
But what he found,
he had a,
this is all fda approved as well.
And if they did these trials out of the
university of New Mexico where they gave
people intravenous dmt,
which is just like they're doing the
intravenous ketamine with you,
you know,
boom,
right into the bloodstream and longterm
effect.
Just like your experience.
Yeah,
it's like a 45 minute trip as opposed to
dmt,
which is like 50 weed.
You smoke it rather,
which is like 15 minutes.
So the aiw osca,
what they've done is they've figured out
a way to have dmt and mao inhibitor and
natural mao inhibitor because monoamine
oxidase,
which is mao dissolve dmt in the gut.
So if you try to take it orally,
your body just breaks it down.
And one of the reasons for that is a dmt
exists in so many different plants that
it was just orally active on its own.
You would get high every time you get no
salad,
will you be tripping your balls off,
you know,
it just,
it would be edible and it just,
you'd be freaking out.
You're there,
your neurotransmitter levels would go
through the fucking roof every time you
eat vegetables.
So he um,
they figured out how to do it with,
you know,
they didn't know in a hospital setting,
just like sort of a year to a doctor's
office setting.
So like what you're doing and um,
they had know really,
really,
really profound results with it to the
point where it was really,
really life changing shit for the people
that were a part of it.
Yeah.
because it's just like a fucking,
it's like having a law.
It's like,
you know,
when you'd see boxers working with like
a weighted vest,
take the vesta.
So that's what you feel like after you
got out of there.
Yeah.
Take the vest off.
YeAh.
And he took the vest off more and more
every time you did it.
Yeah.
And so the sixth one,
after the sixth one's over,
Describe what it's like the next day
after the initial bay,
smaller hangover
now because
hangover and just general.
And I was taking that,
like I said,
the scores would go down.
The um,
the uh,
it's called the bec,
a questionnaire assumption.
Um,
and uh,
and I just feel like I like my dog more
dumb as shit,
but it's like I write more,
I laughed my own jokes more.
I like my dog more.
The other thing that he said,
which I was going to mention of the
things that will make it last longer.
diet health,
exercise.
I'm a talk therapy and a close personal
connection.
So what he said,
close personal connection with someone
with someone with a love.
Yeah.
So I'm on the street,
I'm out on the streets looking,
looking for love in all the wrong
places,
looking for a candIdate,
trying to make this,
make this fucking make this ketamine
last girl.
Now what are you doing for exercise?
A kettlebells and treadmill,
which I always do.
Um,
so,
but it's like one of those.
Just a youtube kettlebell exercise
regimen.
Yeah.
That's hard to motivate yourself.
She'd go to your class.
I don't.
The thing is
I don't have a hard time.
Like when I got my treadmill,
my accountant's lIke,
trust me,
you're never going to use it.
my clients get them.
They're using.
I was like,
I'm irish catholic.
Like,
I'm fucking going to use it.
Trust me.
Like I will be like,
no,
you fucking you motherfucker.
You will.
Well,
I receiveD the a and shit like that
question.
You're,
we'll say,
listen,
he's because he's an asshole.
Did that.
When he.
I invested in that tick,
that laughs stub website that does the
tickets for all the comedy clubs.
I invested in it for five,
six years ago and he's like,
mom,
I don't think it's.
I quadrupled my money.
It was like,
by the way,
my dad's a fucking lawyer.
Like,
I'm not a rube.
My dad work was a tax lawyer.
Like I'm not like,
hey,
wait.
He when I invested in a restaurant
recently,
he's like,
yeah,
you can sit at the corner table.
I'm like,
I'm not doing it to sit at the fucking
corner table.
I'm doing it because I think it's a good
thing.
You need a new accountant.
He sounds like a negative nancy.
he is.
What a dick.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
if I had an account like that,
I'd Be like,
listen,
fuck face.
He's trying to.
he's trying to be cautious.
Yeah,
cautious people are great,
but not that cautious where you're
getting cautious about a fucking
treadmill.
You micromanager.
Yeah.
Just let them buy the treadmill.
Let the kid have some fun.
Let the kid ever fucking exercise
equipment all the time.
Um,
and a kettlebell.
Same thing.
So you feel like a noticeable change
when you have a good workout?
Do you feel like elevated?
You know,
I am yet to get that.
I didn't know at this point I just,
I,
because I wasn't
because I felt shitty and didn't
exercise for like three weeks.
I now I'm like fucking doing kettlebells
and I'm like fuck afterwards just
because I haven't,
I'm out of shape basically.
Right.
So I'm in that like fucking jesus.
So the three weeks while you were
weaning yourself off of the drugs,
the last couple months I just haven't
had time to uh,
to do that shit and I haven't been home
and shit.
So I'm so,
but now that I'm back on it,
I'm hoping I've never had a runner's
high.
You know what I mean?
Really?
Yeah,
you gotta run it.
I'm like,
I've never had a runner's high.
The fuck you talking about.
They'll require sarah town.
I think you've got to go deep to get a
runner's high too.
You've got to be exhausted.
Yeah.
I think it's a.
I can't remember what the,
what the mechanIsm is,
why you get it.
It's like one of those things where your
body thinks you're dying or something.
My buddy cameron hanes just ran a
fucking 24 hour run a mile track.
Twenty four hours.
He did 106 laps.
He ran 106 miles in 24 hours.
His legs swelled up twice.
Their size.
Feet are fucking bleed.
He said videos on instagram of him than
popping these,
uh,
blood volcanoes and his feet pop.
It squirts up in the air.
what did he do it for it to be an
asshole so that everybody knows that he
can run 100 miles.
Body hoped out afterward.
Like,
I guess we're a hope now.
Fuck it.
Let's hook up.
He pushes himself.
He's really into pushing himself.
You know,
like testing is meant.
Mental toughness.
Testing is his mental boundaries because
he ran 100,
six miles fucking psycho.
He's crazy.
He's a professional bowhunter.
He's a crazy guy.
Was it is?
He saId no more.
He regularly throws a hundred and 35
pound rock and his backpack and climbs
up hills to simulate.
Look what it's like the pack out meat
when you're hunting because you got to
these mountain hunters.
Mountain hunting is incredibly difficult
to do physically when you did.
I've done it a couple times,
but the climbing up was the most
shocking.
Like how tireD you get.
Like I'm in shape,
I work out all the time.
I'll climb that mountain bitch.
But he goes,
it's like,
holy fuck you if you.
If you're not doing thAt specifically,
like constantly climbing,
you get fucking exhausted.
So he gets an [inaudible] and then you
miss out on opportunities and he's a
professional.
That's what he does.
So he does it.
He gets in shape literally for that and
then along the way got addicted to
getting in shape,
you know?
And then you get addicted to results and
addicted to perform them came to new.
The other thing I was going to mention
was the sense taking the ketamine.
My recall has gotten better memory.
Yeah.
Because that's the.
The thing that is sort of an unsung
about depression.
It fucks your memory up.
Like you can't recall words.
Well,
it makes sense because memories
increased by upping your
neurotransmitters.
Yeah.
When you take nootropics,
that's one of the things that we found
when we did the double blind placebo
studies on,
at the boston center for memory with um,
alpha brain.
Was that one of the
big markers that had increased in his
memory,
memory and even reaction time,
executive function,
all those things.
Yeah.
You attaching to like,
or the,
the opposite of it.
You were attaching to depressing this
slowness is drag this weight.
Yet the other thing,
last night,
last two nights when I've been at clubs,
I remember everyone's name normally.
I'm like,
I,
I don't,
I think I know your name.
I couldn't tell you what it is.
Like I could see their name next to
their face.
Um,
switch again,
just the weird thing that you don't
think about.
And then when it happened,
like fucking.
okay,
good.
I thought my memory's fucked up.
If I couldn't remember how.
I used to think of you when I first met
you,
like way back at the boston comedy club,
you would never like jovial.
You never like well,
like real happy.
Cool.
We're always,
we always were friendly to each other
and throw the ball around a little.
Yeah.
But you know what I'm saying,
you know,
but I was a kid,
I was like that.
THere was a picture of me as a baby one
or one and a half and I'm like literally
staring at the Picture,
like staring at the camera and chappelle
goes.
And you've had that look on your face
ever since.
Yeah.
You were always kind of stoic.
And it's not in.
The thing is,
it's like the other thing,
it sucks going through life going like I
know there's something better.
I know there's something,
I don't want to be like this.
Like I know that there is a.
I know if I wasn't like this,
life would be more enjoyable and like,
and I know it's not,
you know,
it's the thing with depression is a lot
of times people think it's just like,
oh,
well you don't look.
And it's like when Henry Rollins said
fucking can't believe robin williams
killed himself,
it's like,
well then you don't fucking understand
depression dickhead.
It's not like getting lung cancer
because you didn't even breathe.
Right.
He's got that Whole suck it up attitude
down pat.
Yeah.
But I don't,
I,
I can't subscribe to that.
I've known way too many people that have
had like real fucking problems with it
and I think it can be adjusted with the
behavior modifications,
the way you treat people,
the way you interface with people with
exercise,
with diet a little bit.
There's a lot going on,
but some people,
man,
it's not enough.
Some people are still fucking depressed.
Yeah.
YeaH.
That's.
I've gone to therapy fucking 15 years
already.
Said mushrooms helped him a lot.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people say lIke
mushrooms,
they're trying to.
They're mushrooms is in this whole
ketamine,
a bogus goba he bogus.
I'm abigail.
I've ibogaine.
Yeah,
but the extracts,
um,
I will ask,
uh,
all that shit.
Um,
there's a thing in,
in south America they can go or Costa
Rica that it's like an ego but an
ibogaine retreat and you see there are
videos on this retreat thing.
You see a guy transform it a week and
it's not fake.
Right?
You can see it in his carriage and his
eyes.
It's amazing.
Um,
so yeah,
I think some people just like,
you got to fucking hard to a hard
restart.
Yeah.
Hard restarts are great for phones and
people.
Yeah.
which brings me to the samsung galaxy s
six.
You know,
when you do the math,
it's simple.
Six is greater than six.
What is that?
One of the asset is being beach do punch
up on that,
but they don't.
I can't pick what they pick.
They should listen to you.
I think they're popular though.
They may,
sometimes they're very popular,
But like the,
I think the ads are properly,
so I can't argue with them.
Well,
let's just follow those ads on youtube.
It just on tHe,
in the comments.
It's just everyday.
It's just apple.
Samsung,
apple said,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
Fuck.
It's like,
dude,
you got it.
This can't be that important.
Well,
people get hung up on brands so hard.
You know?
I've had people that I've talked to that
say I'll never buy a ford.
I'm a fucking chevy guy.
You know,
like what is wrong with you?
Yeah,
like how would I don't buy apple,
dude.
I'm a windows guy.
Okay.
Jesus christ.
It would.
If all of a sudden apple comes up with
the greatest thing ever,
you're going to stick to your guns
because they trick you into.
Because it's not about the product.
It hasn't been about the product and
advertising for 20,
30 years.
It's about the cultural meaning of the
thing with especially big brands.
Especially.
That's why like sneaker companies and
Chile that once they go south,
once they are for losers.
Good.
Forget it.
Good luck.
Once you see one homeless guy wearing
them and I'm talking to.
I'm talking to you and one once.
She's.
What?
I would see any like once you see or
like penn one had a day in the sun,
but it's only two years.
Yeah,
but this homeless guy,
I don't know.
It's interesting that I'm sure it's
interesting.
They fucked up their brand.
Yeah.
What other brands would you say are
inexorable and unfixable pony in the
eighties?
Ponies back though.
Date?
No,
they tried.
Puma.
Puma is a little shaky for they will.
There are some that kind of classic.
Some are european companies like uh,
I think nike owns converse and I think
adidas and puma converse all stars never
stopped.
I never went to whenever they hung in
there just by the fact that it's not
expensive and bad ass fucking sneaker.
They just,
they're new,
they're new.
They're like stylish enough and neutral
enough.
Yeah.
They don't call,
they don't go on and on about it,
you know what I mean?
Chuck's all day.
So then there's like a bunch of other
companies that are like new balance.
I'm not sure.
Yeah.
Well new balance.
Some of them are just for runners,
like some are just like a [inaudible] oh
yeah,
new balance.
What about a deed?
Brooks?
Apparently mrs.
Always going to have a certain like
shell tops are always going to have a
certain amount of class.
Yeah.
My.
And now he's got nike's got the uh,
the,
the pro athlete angle.
Yeah.
But they've got like the,
the fucking,
the like the super one that's been like
cool.
That blank dates where the clean ones.
My white,
the clean ones.
I can't think of the name of it.
Do you request in your rider a new pair
of sneakers with every show that you
did?
I do not like eddie griffin.
Yes.
If that shoe sneaker.
It's the white air force one.
Air force wants.
Thank you very much.
So white air force ones they've Liked.
That's a perennIal for them.
A perennial.
Yeah.
And the,
the other one is the uh,
the fucking air.
It's got the,
it was the first one in the bubble when
it used to be timberland's air max air
max.
That is coRrect.
Remember when it used to be timberlands?
Timberlands with no laces.
And I remember I was just there.
Joe,
what?
What happened?
That wasn't jovial.
Didn't work.
Now in certain areas I didn't know,
they never went out.
They never went out in certain areas.
They'd never went.
I it like doc martens with depressed
white people.
That is correct.
Doc martens until there was a,
a big part of the depressed pump.
Wells.
Angry.
Yeah.
they want to be from liverpool.
NoT talking to your parents that thought
my parents were doing heroin,
putting my shoes.
I'll be on st marks if anyone needs me
at doc martens or a weird one.
Like if you wore a doc martens,
you basically look giving up on the rest
of the society and they're not good
looking.
They started like skinheads made them
popular,
like they were like big in the skinhead
community and then they kind of took off
from there.
It's like,
are we share?
Will he represented like a certain
aesthetic like person who's just not
following the norm?
You want dark things?
Clouds?
Yes.
Yeah.
Safety pins and your clothes.
Like the johnny rotten and malcolm
mclaren shit.
Yeah.
Please.
Shelf up by your bootstraps.
Is kevin kevin?
These fucking weirdos?
Yeah.
Um,
So,
uh,
so yeah,
I've got to say so far so good with the
ketamine,
like it's.
No,
that's great to hear that you've found
something that's an actual solution.
yeah.
That at least in this one run I've had,
have had people have um,
have people had an issue similar to way
you were saying that these ssri is,
they would work for a little while,
then they stop working.
Have people had an issue with like this
with ketamine?
I think they've,
my feeling personally is like at a
certain point I'll do something else but
um,
but I don't think it's a matter of
quitting.
I don't know what would have.
I don't think it would be like the ssri
thing is your eight chemicals leaving
your body.
That's the withdrawal,
which creates like any drug withdrawal.
It's just your body's trying to
compensate.
I'm with this.
There's no,
there's no ketamine in me now to speak
of.
I guess there's,
maybe ketamine creates something in your
brain that whatever.
So.
Well,
that's one of the weirdest things about
some psychedelic trips as you feel like
there's rewiring going on,
you feel that with like they're working
in your brain,
like you see them peripherally and
you're looking at you going like doing
some shit off to the side.
That's what I mean.
It's like going back saturday.
Right.
And you're just like,
oh fuck,
this is the.
Oh,
go.
Hey guys,
how are you?
Will you,
I think you're saying,
wait if correct me if I'm wrong,
but what you're seeing is like the roots
of where your behavior is coming from
when you're saying that you see their
wiring under the board.
Uh,
yeah,
I just see more like the board,
the board itself.
Yeah.
And not necessarily like,
oh,
see your childhood,
the lever.
Do you see your child and much see you
in the current state?
I don't,
I don't really see.
I,
it was a pov,
um,
we all know pov from porn as a pov shot
of me basically laying in the same
position as I was on the bed,
which is just like,
you know,
sitting up in the bed.
So it was just me basically at one point
it became like a little rollercoaster,
like,
but a fun kind of smooth like water
ride.
Um,
but it's just me kind of going through
different things.
Um,
and some of the times it was just like
white blob,
you know,
just like,
and you go into it with a mindset where
you're trying to cure your depression or
you're trying to eliminate it or
mitigate it or like I didn't.
Yeah.
I was like,
I'm just hopeful.
Right.
Um,
but why you're having these experiences
while you're on the water slide.
Is this a theme I thinking I'm,
are You just experiencing just kind of
nice and nice feeling and then it's
time.
So it'd be like,
oh fuck,
I'm in santa monica,
I'm trYing to treat depression.
Wow.
And you would think that while you're in
the middle of the trip?
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
And the other thing iS you could,
I could hear the doctors sometimes he'd
be talking.
Oh,
but there was a nurse watching it the
whole time.
A nurse she got,
she's super fucking hunt.
Stephanie if you Listen.
She was cute.
Yeah.
Jo,
she was,
she,
where the pov came in handy.
She's got a corset on.
Yeah,
I'm,
the associate was watching.
She just watches you and I was like,
hey,
would you videotape me?
And she was like,
yeah.
And then I got up and she's like,
you didn't do anything.
So it wasn't really the point,
but I'm supposed to catch me while I'm
under.
So let's say this is be under.
Yeah,
a couple of times.
Got her own artistic skill around
fucking,
you know,
how they get cut down there.
So,
uh,
so yeah,
so there's a nurse watching you and then
there was,
they also use ketamine for pain
management.
If people have had chronic pain that
they can't Get rid of.
Real they.
Yeah.
Ketamine treatment.
Why my academy for that?
The same fucking thing.
Something's going on.
Yeah.
The not knowing why it's effective is
very strange.
Yeah.
And the dosage,
my understanding is the dosage is way
less than people would take on the
street.
And the fact that it's Weightless.
The people taking the street and I Was
still fucking tripping my balls off is,
I don't know what happens on the street.
will the street ones they're taking,
they're
snorting it or they're smoking it.
Oh.
So it's less so maybe it gets cut down
by the body.
Oh god.
I imagine it's getting processed by your
stomach.
You know,
it's going through your,
your organs and all that jazz.
You're just shooting it right into your
blood.
You probably need way less.
Yeah.
Um,
so.
So yeah.
So you should look into lily looking at
john lilley because he really was a
fucking nut for ketamine.
He became addicted to it.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
Well he apparently was,
I can't imagine getting addicted to it
because it's pretty.
I know another guy got a color to it,
like was it a club day?
Well,
A guy who was into it as a club drug,
he got addicted to it and came out here.
A buddy of mine took him out here to
rehab.
He was a fighter.
Took him out to a.
There's a place in thousand oaks.
It's a rehab place that's um,
that specializes or did specialize in
the early two thousands,
specialize in ketamine and he wound up
dying from it.
He died from withdrawal or overdose,
drug overdose,
whatever kind of drug.
Who knows if it was ketamine or a bunch
of other things with ketamine.
But he had a real ketamine problem.
So ketamine,
like recreationally,
I didn't know to.
I wouldn't.
It was like,
you can't fucking trip [inaudible].
I wouldn't want it.
It's like,
what do you want to do?
Shrooms every day.
some people would,
but it's like everything else.
Like,
you know,
should you be able to get a tattoo?
Yeah,
of course.
Well,
some people want a tattoo every part of
their body,
including their eyeballs.
Okay.
Well that's not me,
but yeah,
it,
as long as I can say I want to have a
sleeve.
I can't stop some guy from turning his
eyeballs into towed from thex man or
whatever the fuck he's doing.
His name wasn't towed or something like
that.
Frog fuck's his name of wolverine.
The froggy guy.
I don't think there was a frog and
eczema.
What was he?
The guy With the fucking tail?
Nightcrawler.
Another.
There was nightcrawler and there was
another guy that was like a toad.
Whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
It's crazy to wes borland looking black
eyes.
I wouldn't,
I have,
would have no interest in doing this.
I would like to do it a little.
Is that a different one?
Was that one?
That's a different one.
So that's not,
that's not the frog.
That's not the one I was talking about.
Well,
who the fuck is that?
That's the frog.
I was talking about the.
Oh,
you're talking about somebody else got a
guy who's up there.
The other guY is the guy with that guy
right there.
The guy to the left of that.
The other guy.
That guy.
Yeah.
Oh,
all right.
yeah,
that's what he looked like.
All right.
Whatever.
um,
yeah,
I don't,
I couldn't imagine doing it every.
It was pleasant but it wasn't that
pleasant because the hangovers.
Not like I hate that fucking feeling
coming out of anesthesia.
Like I had a septum surgery and I'm the
guy didn't take out enough shit,
but that's a whole other thing.
But when I came out of it,
um,
it was in New York like a nine years ago
when I came out of it,
it was the fucking worst feeling
coming out of anesthesia and I couldn't
breathe.
I was like,
can I please get some water?
And she was like,
we can't give you water.
So it's that thing where they're like,
mr ron investment,
it's just like this jarring fucking
thing or they're trying to wake you up.
And I was like,
please.
And she's like,
I'm giving you an ice cube.
She gave me an ice cube,
I hocked up a fucking blood pellet.
That was like,
well,
what if I hadn't asked for that shit?
Like I couldn't.
It was dangerous.
Um,
so You had swallowed like clot
basically.
Yeah.
In a clot,
like blood booger was pictures on
twitter after I got my deviated septum
done while I was blowing out these
fucking silver dollar size hunks of
blood and bulger.
Ooh,
you got enough meat.
They guy didn't taken enough.
Meet up.
Yeah,
my guy was awesome.
He did a great job.
I almost want to get it again.
Get it again.
All right,
I love it man.
Now that I've come out of the fucking
ketamine,
maybe I can double up having nose,
nose breathing,
being able to breathe through my nose
that I didn't get that.
So it was like 40 or 39.
I think I had it.
I still can't really breathe that in one
of my.
Yeah.
For me it's magic.
Can you imagine the kind of shape I'd
been fired.
I'm terrified.
Fucking fucking guy.
You guys got to know what to do.
Well,
it's just nice to be able to breathe
just to be able to breathe in your nose
with your mouth closed.
That was a mouth breather most of my
life,
but I apparently it's not an easy
surgery and some people just,
it doesn't work right on them,
you know?
And some people grow back.
That's the other thing I heard you goes
back to it.
I've heard it just repeats.
Know mine hasn't.
Okay.
Milo on seven years,
so it's amazing.
Yeah.
They,
they trim your turbinates.
I think they're called those big bones
in there and they also cut out a lot of
calcified blood on me.
Oh really?
Yeah,
mine was all like they.
There was like an extra that goes like I
don't think you need anything,
and then he showed he did like the x ray
and it.
There was so much like cartilage or
whatever it was.
It was like it was cinnamon buns to fit.
Oh god.
So I guess he took that uP,
but he didn't take out enough shit.
They say that there's a large percentage
of people that deal with block septums
that it's super confident because your
nose is so fragile.
You whacked it on a door and all of a
sudden it's bent and now you don't
breathe right for the rest of your life.
So you get an operation.
The I've heard whether it's true or not,
but like a lot of it has to do with
inbreeding.
I really have.
I've heard the jewish people and irish
people have fucked up noses from
inbreeding.
Really?
Where'd you read that?
In fucking on reddit,
bro.
Where do you think I bucket or it?
Well,
you know how fighters get cauliflower
ear?
Yeah,
rough.
They get that with their nose as well.
You get it with your nose,
the inside of your nose.
Yeah.
The inside is soft tissue inside your
nose,
bleeds and swells and fills with blood
and that blood hardens and calcifies and
there's nothing you can kind of get in
there and scrape it out.
Got to get an operation if you don't do
anything for cauliflower ear.
Yeah,
yeah.
The cut,
the cut the ear,
they flay it open and then they scrape
out all the calcification and stitch it
right by the ear.
Yeah.
It's just blood that becomes calcified
when blood leaks,
like when you have breaks in the blood
vessels apparently,
and it's under the surface of the skin.
It swells up,
like fills up with blood and then that
blood hardens and becomes like calcium.
I,
uh,
someone I know was telling me that they
woke up with vertigo and it turned out,
um,
because a friend of hers had had it for
months and they go,
yeah,
it turned out it was just a piece of
dust in my inner ear.
So basicaLly if you ever wake up with
vertigo,
one of the ways you get rid of it is
literally like trying to get water out
of your head.
You're trying to just jar the dust or
whatever it is.
I'm like somersaults,
fucking laying on your side.
I swear to god they was like,
somersaults is one of the cures.
Um,
so if anyone wakes up with vertigo,
get to.
Was it that your ears control your
balance?
Like some of her nose,
your ears and your balance are
connected.
Yeah.
And your nose and your taste buds are
connected.
Yeah.
Fuck is going on with the human design.
What a shit design.
And you're on the outside.
Yeah.
And every time.
No god you come,
you can make a person.
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
It's too wild.
It's ridiculous.
Trick.
Trick us.
Yes.
So,
uh,
so yeah,
tricks.
So I'm,
look,
man,
I'm happy to hear that.
You know,
this is really working for you.
Yeah.
I'm still not.
I think I'm still not.
I'm hoping that I have maYbe 30 more
percent upside to go more room.
I think it with the ssri stuff like once
then completely dissipates.
Yeah.
But I'm like,
it's more enjoyAble from the pov than it
was.
Would you recommend this to other
people?
Do you recommend?
I wouldn't,
you know,
recommending a medical treatment.
It's,
it's personal,
but if you feel like all I can tell you
is I tried a bunch of shit and it's.
And it's true.
The reason they do ketamine,
there's another one called tms,
which is the magnetic one.
There's a guy in chicago who does both
at the same time cheats us prices guys.
A mad man.
Fuck You.
Trying to do like a superman and uh,
he might've.
So Yeah.
So,
uh,
you're the doctor.
I'm so you.
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
there's a bunch of shit and it's like if
you're just sick of it,
I was just sick enough of it that I was
like,
I don't name the price named the
hardship because there's nothing.
I'm just sick of it.
Well,
you know,
kudos to you for keeping.
Keep searching.
The transcranial magnetic stimulation is
covered by some.
With magnets on your head.
Yes.
And they don't know how it works,
but they got it.
And I was on a show the other night,
by the way,
it was like a science show,
science slash comedy show,
like the panelists that were scientists
panels over comics.
A woman on the panel,
um,
has,
she's involved in a magnet thing that
increases people's sex drive for ever
fucking chicks.
Yeah.
Shoot magnets and your way.
Hornier.
And I was like,
do you think who?
But I said,
I don't think men need it.
Right?
Because the judge fuck your life.
The idea is you give it to women.
Yeah.
Like it's a spanish fly and magnet
basically.
Yeah.
So while you check is asleep,
he put a fucking kitchen magnets out,
joe people online that was saying they
can make it at home.
Not the,
not the sex one,
but the transcranial one.
But um,
well there's been all sorts of magnetic
pulse to ease depression.
Yeah.
Wow.
What does It say?
Noninvasive procedure to help fight
depression called transcranial magnetic
stimulation or tms uses magnetic pulse
to stimulate brain cells that control
moot,
but they use that transcranial
stimulation for a lot of different shit.
Right?
There Was a,
not magnetics but electric.
They were.
They had these electrodes they were
attaching to people's brains that helped
them learn shit quicker.
There's all sorts of weird little hacks
that you can use that helps stimulate
little areas of the brain that they
covered on radio lab.
There was a radio lab episode about this
woman who went through a sniper school
tests when I heard that one.
you see that one?
Yeah.
That one was a main.
Or listen to that one.
That one was amazing because she did it
and then she did it the second time and
she's like,
everything was in slow motion.
I feel.
Felt like it only took five minutes and
it was 20 minutes later,
the eight.
A zone the zone now.
so,
uh,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
I love this.
I love that there's so many people
working on all these different ways to
improve the way the brain functions and
they're kind of still in this infancy
with it.
They're fucking with it and adding
pills.
I'm grateful for the shit they've done
so far.
It's like fucking thank you.
Even for the pills that didn't work.
Trying.
Yeah.
That's really cool.
I've never had a depression issue.
I don't think.
I mean I think I might've when I was
really young,
but I don't have it.
I definitely don't have it now,
but I,
I sympathize with it and I know a lot of
people who have had it and I know a lot
of people have had it and they've come
back and they're much better.
You know,
our fears.
One that I always point to ari was
severely depressed at one point in time
and you know,
and now he's just amazing.
He's happiest fucker.
I know.
From what terms you think that a lot to
do with it.
Success had a lot to do with it or he's
really successful now and you know,
he doesn't feel like he's on the outside
anymore.
He's not,
he felt like,
I think for awhile like that he wasn't
being recognized,
he was being recognized by us,
you know,
like all of our friends and like crowds
would laugh at them but the industry
doesn't take them or he wasn't.
YeAh,
I had another brain thing over two days.
I think it was earlier this week,
um,
where one day I was like,
fucking no one cares about you and the
next day I like,
it was a professional gripe,
warm legacy field,
getting,
doing good enough it to all that shit.
And then the next day I had the same
thought and then it was followed by like
will then fight,
you know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
like yeah,
it was like then fucking do something
about it.
Whereas the day before I was just like
hopeless.
Like that's the thing is like one of the
depression thinks just like learned
helplessness is a sin.
They think that was one of the things
that like that was a behavioral thing
where it's like you have to like when,
when mice couldn't,
when they realized they couldn't get out
of a box,
they just stopped trying,
but then there were certain meds that
they gave I think a chemical to that
would keep,
that would like just fight,
fight,
fight until he died.
but they.
But that was the thing of like,
okay,
like I wasn't getting out a month ago.
That learned vIctim mentality is that
that's a,
a groove that's like carved in people
and some people it's become so
prominent.
Yeah.
They just automatically drop right into
that.
And then they're a victim.
Yeah.
And they search for that and then they
use it.
Look for situations.
I also use it in arguments,
like they become a victim in the
argument.
It's super common and it's so self
defeating,
but so it's so enormous part of really
weak thinking.
Yeah.
But having said that,
a lot of some of week thinking is as
chemical problem is fucking diabetes.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Exactly.
And also,
not everybody has the same exact fuckIng
childhood and growing up experiences.
So your,
your formative experiences that you're
having with it's shaping your
personality,
what giant percentage of them are
completely out of your control and how
arrogant is it to assume that everybody
had the experiences that you had.
So you've gotten through them.
Everybody else,
Henry Rollins needs to pull themselves
up by their bootstraps and not fucking
shoot themselves.
Like robin williams,
that pussy fucking pussy.
Yeah,
I mean that's the crazy.
Well that's like when people say it
like a,
a,
a depression is like a strength thing.
It's like if you're talking about mental
fortitude,
I've got a pretty good track record of
like shit I've done.
and same with robin williams talking
about fucking not easy.
What he's done.
Fucking write however many hours to
stand up.
He stole a ton of stand up to be that
good inactive to being just his recall
was fucking a like.
He's got a good brain so he's not like a
week at
some things.
At least you know Mark Gordon,
who's a good friend of mine,
is a doctor.
He's an expert in traumatic brain injury
and recovery from traumatic brain injury
and one of the things that he talked
about,
he actually wrote a paper about this,
about people that have gone through very
significant operations where they have
been under anesthesia for long periods
of time and had open heart.
That type of shit.
There's a large percentage of them that
experience and pretty significant
depression after it's over and they
think it has to do with hormonal
imbalances that occur after these
traumatic.
Yeah.
That,
but some people have like a kind of.
Seems like letterman had the opposite,
like he had heart surgery and was like a
new man.
He was just appreciative and shit like
that.
Well,
that's true too.
You know,
some people that go through these near
la near death experiences and wakes them
up like they realize,
hey asshole,
this is almost over.
Maybe it's time to be nice to people.
Yeah.
Maybe appreciate,
smell the flowers.
You're fucking.
David letterman did go out and hug some
folks,
you know?
Yeah.
That's.
He'd started taking antidepressants.
did he really?
Yeah,
he was on alec baldwin's podcast.
He talked about it like alec baldwin as
a pilot,
baldwin hat.
He had a podcast.
I don't know if it came back.
That guy's got golden pipes,
first of all.
So that's the way he talks.
A joy what you're saying.
This is alec baldwin.
I'm like,
it's a joy to listen to that puck.
That's an easy hour,
right?
There's ego.
It was fucking try to fucking like,
don't pay attention to that part.
You'll listen to fucking golden.
But I'll take an ego with pipes like
that.
What have you have?
Puffer razzi.
Would you hold a grudge?
Yeah,
I think that's what made him,
it was on a public radio station in New
York and they were like,
you can't be saying faggot and all that,
like,
sorry man,
I can't say I can't do it.
But uh,
but yeah,
so he was talking about on,
on,
on alex pod podcast and it was like,
he went on him shortly after that.
I think he had shingles too,
and he was just miserable.
Uh,
and they were like going in and he's
like,
really?
And he said like,
it's,
I don't know what the analogy was,
but he's like,
it was just like,
it was like I'd clumpy hair that I
couldn't get a comb through and now I
could get the comfort with or something.
I don't remember what the,
but some similar to that,
but he's kind of chubby and it doesn't
go.
you exercises and I bet he doesn't eat
letterman.
No,
no.
I'm taLking about letterman,
letterman,
letterman would talked about it.
Ios podcast,
not on antidepressants.
These podcasts.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
letterman also,
this is post open heart surgery.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
But I'd heard stories about him where he
was,
you know,
I'd hear stories where he wouldn't be
happy with the monologue.
And he used to be banging his head
against the wall.
Yeah,
I heard that too.
I heard that from my friend who's his
assistant.
Yeah.
He fucking hated everything he did.
and that's one of the reasons why he was
the best.
Yeah.
It's just the way it is.
Yeah,
he would.
Yeah.
There's a,
there was a story in that,
uh,
in that late night book,
the late shift that I think it was in
the book,
but Peter Le sally had a big house in
malibu and he was the exec producer of
the tonight show and like an exec
producer on late night with david
letterman and he became one on the new
one too,
but,
so he was sort of like,
letterman's go between for letter for
uh,
for johnny and uh,
he had a beautiful rooms like,
man,
I could never have a house like this.
And he goes,
you make 10 times the money I make,
like you could totally.
And he's Like,
really?
Like,
it just never occurred to him that
things were good and he could do well.
Another thing more.
I'm more apt to cry now as well in a
good way.
Not like,
like I saw inside out and cried,
which isn't good.
Yeah.
Sweet.
but uh,
but like,
so you feel more?
Yeah.
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
So far
I'm happy for you to get addicted and
die.
I think that's awesome.
I'm happy for you coming on here and
talking about it because it's fucking
because the thing with therapy that it's
very,
first of all,
people don't know.
It's very hard to find a good therapist.
Like people are too quick to go,
like,
yeah,
they're fine.
You got to shop around which people
don't realize and with the
antidepressants you gotta shop around
and if none of them work,
keep looking for other shit.
Like don't just go and you can't do it.
Um,
so.
So yeah.
But uh,
I look forward to the rest of my life,
jo.
I look forward to hanging out with you,
neil brennan.
You're a bad motherfucker.
Thanks.
but I appreciate it.
I appreciate you coming on.
I appreciate you talking about this.
Oh yeah,
no problem.
Neil motherfucking brennan.
Follow him on twitter and instagram and
website.
The other website.
Neil?
Brendon.com.
I don't know.
I don't know what's going on.
They're like raccoons and shit at this
point.
Websites anymore websites or social
media?
Social media is taken.
It's too effective.
Alright,
fogarty,
hers will be back with podcast number
six,
six on monday.
And who's the gas?
Duncan trussell.
Of course.
Praise satan or allah or whoever you
like.
All right.
Love you fuckers.
See you soon.
Bye.